We're coming up on five years. I know, isn't that amazing? So then how many episodes is that? We've been doing one week for five years. We're gonna be 250 episodes in, I don't know. And 25 is the silver, 50 is the gold. Is there anything for 250? Is that triple silver?
我们快要满五年了。我知道，这不是很神奇吗？那算下来是多少集呢？我们每周一集，坚持了五年。我们大概会做到250集，我也不确定。25年是银婚，50年是金婚。250集有什么说法吗？是三倍银婚吗？
It's, What is it? What is it centennial? Wasn't it like- Wait guys, this is our 250th episode. Also known as- Come on. 250th! Bravo, bravo!
是什么呢？是百年纪念吗？不是那种……等等，伙计们，这是我们的第250集。也就是所谓的——来吧。第250集！太棒了，太棒了！
Bravo! Welcome guys, so nice to be here. Oh, you came from the back of the theater. Yeah, I came. I finally made it my way to the front. Nice to see you guys. Look at you guys. Anyway, hey listen, do you mind if I drop some beats on you? That'd be okay.
太棒了！欢迎大家，很高兴能来到这里。哦，你是从剧院后面走过来的。是的，我来了。我终于走到前面来了。很高兴见到你们。看看你们。总之，嘿，听着，介意我给你们来点节奏吗？那应该没问题吧。
Let me tell you something about, just close Riviera, 1982, white Ferrari Mondial. Puff, puff, screaming down the autostrada. You have a cenzano with eyes. Okay, now you're feeling the vibe, huh? Listen, let me ask you something. When you're making a podcast, everybody wants to know what's that old-fashioned recipe. But one thing, one favore, testa ligare, svitato, what I'm trying to say is, smile Huh? Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima Ba-la, ba-la Hey!
让我给你们讲点事，就在里维埃拉，1982年，白色法拉利Mondial。呼，呼，在高速公路上飞驰。你手里拿着一杯金巴利，眼里闪着光。好了，现在你感受到那种氛围了吧，嗯？听着，让我问你一件事。当你制作播客时，每个人都想知道那个老派的秘诀是什么。但有一件事，一个请求，testa ligare, svitato，我想说的是，微笑，嗯？Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima Ba-la, ba-la 嘿！
Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima Ba-la, ba-la Whatever! Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima Ba-la, ba-la I love you! Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima Oh!
Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima Ba-la, ba-la 管他呢！Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima Ba-la, ba-la 我爱你！Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima 哦！
Ba-la, ba-la If you want to do one thing in this year, get Smiless250. Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima Shani, have you been a... Do one thing in this year, get Smiles 250. 250th. Shawnee, how have you been? It's been a minute. My nephew and his girlfriend and three friends are visiting in town this weekend, which is super fun.
Ba-la, ba-la 如果你今年只想做一件事，那就去听Smiless250。Duai-Cento-Cinquantesima Shani，你一直……今年只做一件事，去听Smiles 250。第250集。Shawnee，你最近怎么样？好久不见了。我侄子和他女朋友还有三个朋友这个周末来城里玩，这超级有趣。
Wait, are we going to see them tonight? No, I know. I think it's too many people. Right. So you're not going to go. Am I going to see you tonight? No. What? I know, I think it's too many people. Right. So you're not gonna go. Am I gonna see you tonight? No. What?
等等，我们今晚要见他们吗？不，我知道。我觉得人太多了。对。所以你不打算去了。我今晚能见到你吗？不。什么？我知道，我觉得人太多了。对。所以你不打算去了。我今晚能见到你吗？不。什么？
I know, it's gonna be bad. But I don't get to see my nephew and everybody. I feel bad. You saw them last night, right? Why don't you come over here afterwards? That'll never happen. Oh yeah, that'll happen. Hey, yeah, Jason, why don't you come over there afterwards? Right around 8.. Oh yeah, that'll happen. Hey, yeah, Jason, why don't you come over there afterwards?
我知道，这会很糟糕。但我没能见到我侄子他们。我感觉很不好。你昨晚见到他们了，对吧？你为什么不之后过来这边呢？那永远不会发生的。哦，是的，那会发生的。嘿，是的，Jason，你为什么不之后过来那边呢？就在8点左右……哦，是的，那会发生的。嘿，是的，Jason，你为什么不之后过来那边呢？
Right around 8.30 or something, drive across the city and spend another two hours. This will happen for sure. Yeah, but last night, I took him to Koi, right, last night? Sure you did. And I was. Oh yeah, your favorite tea food restaurant. It was so good, and I was walking back to the car
就在8点半左右，开车穿过城市，再花两个小时。这肯定会发生的。是的，但昨晚，我带他去了Koi，对吧，昨晚？你当然带了。而且我当时……哦，是的，你最喜欢的茶餐厅。真的很好吃，我走回车里的时候
and there was a pothole that I thought was just like a surface puddle and it was a massive pothole and I completely twisted my ankle. It was so fucking painful. Look at that. Is it all swollen? Yeah, it's huge. Come here, bubbins.
那里有个坑，我以为只是个水坑，结果是个巨大的坑，我把脚踝完全扭伤了。真是痛死我了。看看那个。肿了吗？是的，肿得很大。过来，宝贝。
Well, you can't see it, it's huge. No, I can see that. You iced it. This is gonna heal fast, right? Like I freaked out last night. Probably not, it'll probably heal the wrong way and you'll be clubbed. Do you know the term clubfoot?
好吧，你看不见，它肿得很大。不，我能看见。你冰敷过了。这会好得很快，对吧？我昨晚吓坏了。可能不会，它可能会长歪，然后你会变成畸形足。你知道畸形足这个词吗？
Deadfoot. Well, but fortunately it's not going to take anything away from your life. Usually it means that you can't be playing basketball or doing all the jogging and all that stuff. Luckily you don't do any of it. Yeah, that's true. Is that what you're getting at, Jason?
死脚。好吧，但幸运的是，这不会影响你的生活。通常这意味着你不能打篮球或慢跑之类的。幸运的是你什么都不做。是的，那是真的。Jason，你是在说这个吗？
Yeah, you'll still be able to shuffle into chin chin for lunch and koi for dinner. Shuffle. What if you go to the doctor and you're like, will this affect my ability to watch TV all day? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
是的，你还是可以拖着脚去Chin Chin吃午饭，去Koi吃晚饭。拖着脚。如果你去看医生，然后说，这会影响我整天看电视的能力吗？是的。是的。是的。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, no, I just prop it up on the couch. That's what I've been doing. Will I still be able to chop celery into my egg salad? No tuna salad. Well, I have to cut my sloppy Joe intake.
是的。是的。是的。好吧，不，我只是把它垫在沙发上。我一直都是这么做的。我还能切芹菜放进我的蛋沙拉里吗？不，是金枪鱼沙拉。好吧，我得减少我的乔氏三明治摄入量了。
You know what though, here's the deal. They went to the Tar Pits, you know the La Brea Tar Pits near the museum. They being your nephew. My nephew and girlfriend and their friends. Is that still a tourist attraction here? It is, they've never been. And they bought crickets.
不过你知道吗，重点是。他们去了沥青坑，你知道博物馆附近的拉布雷亚沥青坑吗。他们指的是你侄子。我侄子、女朋友和他们的朋友。那现在还是个旅游景点吗？是的，他们从来没去过。而且他们买了蟋蟀。
They bought a bag of crickets and they ate them. Sour cream and onion crickets. And they pulled them out. What does that have to do with the, okay, go ahead. Because they're saying the dinosaurs used to eat crickets back in the tar pit days. Why do they sell those? No, no, no, no, no, they sell them in the gift shop.
他们买了一袋蟋蟀，然后吃了。酸奶油洋葱味蟋蟀。他们把它们拿出来。那和那个有什么关系，好吧，继续。因为他们说恐龙在沥青坑时代常吃蟋蟀。他们为什么要卖那些？不，不，不，不，不，他们在礼品店卖。
They sell them in the gift shop. Why? I have no idea. At the museum? Yes, and they pulled them, you want one? I'm like, no, I'm not gonna eat a cricket. Oh God. Why not?
他们在礼品店卖。为什么？我不知道。在博物馆里？是的，他们拿出来，你想要一个吗？我说，不，我才不吃蟋蟀。哦，天哪。为什么不？
The last time I heard crickets was Good Night Oscar. It was right after the curtain went down. But that's a... Look at him, he's on fire today. He's on fuego. Who would do the worst at some sort of like outdoor survivor type of show where you got a guy I'd last two seconds I'd last no, but I think I wouldn't I think I might do even worse
我最后一次听到蟋蟀声是在《晚安奥斯卡》演出时。就在幕布落下之后。但那是个……看看他，他今天状态火热。他简直太棒了。谁在那种户外生存类节目里表现最差，那种你得……我两秒钟就挂了，我不会……不，但我认为我可能表现得更差。
Well, you would call your lawyer and say am I obligated to eat this Imagine if we took the word obligation out of your vocabulary you weren't allowed to his obligation Yeah, I mean I need new shtick. I'm sick of my own fucking voice. I'm going to be silent today on the podcast. We love your voice. I miss both you guys a lot. I know, I haven't seen you.
好吧，你会打电话给你的律师说，我有义务吃这个吗？想象一下，如果我们把“义务”这个词从你的词汇表中删掉，你不被允许……他的义务。是的，我的意思是，我需要新的噱头。我厌倦了我自己该死的声音。我今天在播客里要保持沉默。我们爱你的声音。我非常想念你们俩。我知道，我没见到你。
I'm so bummed I'm not going tonight. I've been in New York and I've been with lots of friends and lots of people and obviously with Bradley, but I really miss you guys a lot. I know, likewise. I miss you too. I was thinking about you this morning. I'm so jealous. I miss you too. I think I really did. I'm so jealous, I can't see you.
我没能去今晚的聚会真是太沮丧了。我在纽约，和很多朋友、很多人在一起，当然还有Bradley，但我真的非常想念你们。我知道，我也是。我今天早上还在想你。我太嫉妒了。我也想你。我想我真的想了。我太嫉妒了，我见不到你。
Anyway, here we go. Speaking of can't wait to see people, I can't wait for you to see our guest today. Oh, great opening line. This person is someone we all, thank you, thank you. She's someone we all know well. So much so that I'm not sure what I can say about her
总之，我们开始吧。说到迫不及待想见到大家，我迫不及待想让你们见到我们今天的嘉宾。哦，很棒的开场白。这个人是我们大家都……谢谢，谢谢。她是我们大家都非常熟悉的人。以至于我不知道我能说些什么
that won't give it away. But she's a prolific comedian, she's an author, super producer, really great director. She played Dorothy in The Wizard of Oz when she was 10. And more recently, I think she played Elphaba in the movie Wicked, I don't know. A Boston, she didn't. A Boston native, her summer job was working
而不会剧透。但她是一位多产的喜剧演员、作家、超级制片人，非常出色的导演。她在10岁时在《绿野仙踪》中饰演了多萝西。最近，我想她在电影《魔法坏女巫》中饰演了艾尔法巴，我不知道。波士顿人，她的暑期工作是在
at an ice cream parlor where she'd sing Happy Birthday with Kazooz. Today she's a comedic force in Hollywood. Hilarious, colleague! And the world's favorite cool mom, the Regina George, is our ridiculously funny friend, Amy Poehler. No way! Wait, truly?
一家冰淇淋店，她会用卡祖笛唱《生日快乐》。今天她是好莱坞的喜剧力量。搞笑，同事！也是全世界最酷的妈妈，瑞吉娜·乔治，就是我们极其风趣的朋友，艾米·波勒。不会吧！等等，真的吗？
I feel invited, I guess so! Well, well, well. Wait a second! Holy shit! Well, well, well. Wait a second. First of all, how many levels am I involved in? Wait a second. Holy shit. Well, well, well. Wait a second. First of all, how many levels am I?
我感觉被邀请了，我想是的！好吧，好吧，好吧。等一下！天哪！好吧，好吧，好吧。等一下。首先，我参与了多少个层面？等一下。天哪！好吧，好吧，好吧。等一下。首先，我参与了多少个层面？
I know, this is what, of course my first question is, did you know about this? And of course. No. Okay, good, I love it. Not a glimpse of recognition on Will's face when you said all of those things. There's no way that I thought, well, I knew that you worked at Brigham's,
我知道，这是什么，当然我的第一个问题是，你知道这件事吗？当然。不。好吧，很好，我喜欢。当你说了所有那些话时，威尔脸上一点认出的表情都没有。我不可能想到，好吧，我知道你在Brigham's工作过，
but I didn't in Boston. Chadwick's, Will. Oh, Chadwick. you worked at Brigham's, but I didn't, in Boston. Chadwick's, Will, I worked at Chadwick's. No, sorry. Unbelievable. But we went to Brigham's with your dad and he asked the people if they liked their job. Yeah, let him finish, Amy. Yeah.
但我不知道是在波士顿。Chadwick's，威尔。哦，Chadwick's。你在Brigham's工作过，但我不知道，在波士顿。Chadwick's，威尔，我在Chadwick's工作。不，抱歉。难以置信。但我们和你爸爸去了Brigham's，他问员工喜不喜欢他们的工作。是的，让他说完，艾米。是的。
I can't believe this. Wait, Amy, did you have to, because of kid stuff, did you have to like say, oh, I can't, or whatever, or some schedule stuff and lie or something? You know what, it was really easy to hide it. Nobody was asking if I was doing it. Okay. Do you think Archie and Abel would have been able
我简直不敢相信。等等，艾米，你是因为孩子的事情，不得不说，哦，我不行，或者类似的事情，或者一些日程安排的事情，然后撒谎了吗？你知道吗，隐藏它真的很容易。没人问我是否在做这件事。好吧。你觉得Archie和Abel能
to keep the secret? Did you not tell them? Well, I think one of them knew. One of them knew. One of them saw, our youngest saw my schedule on the kitchen table and said, you're doing smart lists. Oh wow. Does dad know?
保守这个秘密吗？你没告诉他们吗？嗯，我想其中一个知道。其中一个知道。其中一个看到了，我们最小的孩子在餐桌上看到了我的日程表，说，你在做Smartless。哦，哇。爸爸知道吗？
No way. And I said, no, don't say anything. I love it. People kept the secret. It's so cool. Wait, and also Amy and I were texting last night about something else, zero. That's good, that's good.
不可能。我说，不，什么都别说。我喜欢。大家保守了秘密。太酷了。等等，而且艾米和我昨晚还在发短信聊别的事情，零。那很好，那很好。
That is unbelievable. I can't. Amy, I didn't know what to say. I didn't know how to introduce you without them not following it. Sean, I'm so honored to be your guest, Sean, of all three. Likewise. First of all, I've asked her to do it and she said no,
这太不可思议了。我不能。艾米，我不知道该说什么。我不知道怎么介绍你，他们才不会跟不上。Sean，我很荣幸能成为你的嘉宾，Sean，三位中的一位。我也是。首先，我邀请她来，她说不，
and then she said yes to Sean. Well, I wanted to wait until you had done 250 episodes to see if this thing was real. Wait, really? I know we've been trying to get you on for so long, and it's so kind of worked out. Well, I usually give something five years before I try it. Sure, sure.
然后她对Sean说了好。嗯，我想等到你做了250集之后，看看这东西是不是真的。等等，真的吗？我知道我们一直想请你来，而且这真的很凑巧。嗯，我通常在尝试某件事之前会给它五年时间。当然，当然。
Bob. Wait, Will, how many times have you asked her to do it? A couple times. I asked you to do it on tour, I think, right, Amy? Yeah, I think so, yeah. But, you know, it just had to, I just was waiting, I was waiting for my buddy Sean to give me the go ahead.
鲍勃。等等，威尔，你邀请过她多少次？几次。我想是在巡演时邀请你的，对吧，艾米？是的，我想是的，是的。但是，你知道，只是需要，我只是在等我的好哥们Sean给我开绿灯。
Here I am, here I am. I gave her the green light and she showed up. Like a race car. Hang on one second, hang on. Amanda, get over here. What? Um, but wait, Sean, did you think for a second, like wait, should I, is this cool?
我在这儿，我在这儿。我给了她绿灯，她就出现了。像辆赛车。等一下，等一下。Amanda，过来。什么？嗯，但是等等，Sean，你有没有想过，比如等等，我应该，这酷吗？
Like did you ask Bennett or Rob to like kind of float it by will to see if that. Yeah, no, I mean, Amy's been on my list. What are you guys talking about? Why do you have to float anything past anybody? Well, we kind of do that every once in a while. Guys, nice, by the way, great welcome. Nice to see you all. Hi.
比如你有没有问Bennett或Rob，让他们去跟威尔透个风，看看……是的，不，我的意思是，艾米一直在我的名单上。你们在说什么？为什么你们必须跟任何人透风？嗯，我们偶尔会那样做。伙计们，顺便说一句，很棒的欢迎。很高兴见到你们所有人。嗨。
I mean, Jesus, you're all talking about how weird it is that I'm here. Hi, I'm your guest. Nice to see you. Oh, hi. Good Lord. First of all, you can't take over our podcast. You can't tell us.
我的意思是，天哪，你们都在谈论我在这里有多奇怪。嗨，我是你们的嘉宾。很高兴见到你们。哦，嗨。天哪。首先，你不能接管我们的播客。你不能告诉我们。
No, it's the only way to talk on this podcast is to completely take it over. 100%. Believe me. It's unbearable if the guest doesn't, because you make us sit and listen to you in the beginning anyway. And it's torturous. It's torturous. It's unbearable if the guest doesn't. Because you make us sit and listen to you in the beginning anyway. And it's torturous.
不，在这个播客上说话的唯一方式就是完全接管它。100%。相信我。如果嘉宾不这样做，那就太难受了，因为反正你们一开始就让我们坐着听你们说话。这简直是折磨。这简直是折磨。如果嘉宾不这样做，那就太难受了。因为反正你们一开始就让我们坐着听你们说话。这简直是折磨。
It's torturous. It's unbelievable. What do you think about how- And every single time I hear you guys talk about how much you miss each other. And am I wrong that you talk to each other every week? No, this is it. We don't get to see each other.
这简直是折磨。这太不可思议了。你觉得怎么样——而且每次我听到你们谈论你们有多想念对方。我没说错吧，你们每周都通话？不，就是这样。我们没机会见面。
We don't get to see each other. First of all, slow down. I'm outraged like five outrages ago. Okay? This is so great. Wait, wait, for Tracy, just so, just to really air, right, for my sister. Of course.
我们没机会见面。首先，慢点。我愤怒得像五次愤怒之前一样。好吗？这太棒了。等等，等等，为了Tracy，只是为了，真的要播出来，对吧，为了我妹妹。当然。
You guys were married and now you're not and it's been years and years. Everything's going swimmingly. What a great way to put it. Anyway, let me be the first to say welcome to Smart Music. Thank you, thank you. We're 17 minutes in, but thank you for that. Amy, this is so great.
你们结婚了，现在没有了，已经过去好多年了。一切都进行得很顺利。这话说得真好。总之，让我第一个说欢迎来到Smartless。谢谢，谢谢。我们已经进行了17分钟了，但还是谢谢你。艾米，这太棒了。
And great crickets joke, by the way, Will. That was a really good crickets joke. That was a good one. Very, very smart, very sharp. Thank you. Jason, are you okay with your mic? Yeah, I'm having a real mic issue this morning. Is it bad for you guys?
顺便说一句，威尔，很棒的蟋蟀笑话。那真是一个很好的蟋蟀笑话。那是一个很好的。非常，非常聪明，非常敏锐。谢谢。Jason，你的麦克风没问题吧？是的，我今天早上麦克风出了点问题。对你们来说很糟糕吗？
Is this bad for me? No, it sounds great. It sounds fine. Now, so Amy, Will, how did you guys first meet? Yeah, we're gonna get into it. No, we're definitely not. When did it first start to fracture? No, we're definitely not.
这对我很糟糕吗？不，听起来很棒。听起来很好。那么，艾米，威尔，你们是怎么认识的？是的，我们要深入了解一下。不，我们绝对不会。什么时候开始出现裂痕的？不，我们绝对不会。
We're definitely not. Amy, it first start to fracture? No, we're definitely not. We're definitely not. Amy, can I tell this story about, you and I were talking about, about Sedaris the other day. Oh yeah, that's a good, yeah, that's a very funny story. So, and I think I maybe told it once before, but you guys- Great, great Amy Sedaris story. So Amy Sedaris, who's working with us on the film,
我们绝对不会。艾米，什么时候开始出现裂痕的？不，我们绝对不会。我们绝对不会。艾米，我能讲讲那个故事吗，关于你和我那天在谈论Sedaris的事。哦，是的，那是个好故事，是的，那是一个非常有趣的故事。所以，我想我可能之前讲过一次，但你们——很棒的艾米·塞达里斯故事。所以艾米·塞达里斯，她和我们一起拍电影，
I was hanging out with her the other day, and she, years ago, Amy Poehler and Amy Sedaris would often get mixed up for each other, because they're both comedians, and they're both sort of blonde and kind of, you know. Cute and funny and talented and charming. Fun and sassy. And I've been with Poehler a million times where people would say to, remember,
我那天和她在一起，她，多年前，艾米·波勒和艾米·塞达里斯经常被搞混，因为她们都是喜剧演员，而且她们都是金发，而且有点，你知道。可爱、有趣、有才华、迷人。有趣又时髦。我和波勒在一起过一百万次，人们会说，记得吗，
they'd go like, I'm such a fan of your brother. And you're like, oh, he's a lawyer, thank you. He'll really appreciate that. I mean, so, so, so I guess it happened to Sedaris too. And one time, like 20 years ago, I read this article in a magazine where Sedaris says, people come up to me all the time and say, oh my God, I love you so great.
他们会说，我是你哥哥的忠实粉丝。然后你会说，哦，他是律师，谢谢。他会非常感激的。我的意思是，所以，所以，所以我猜这也发生在塞达里斯身上。有一次，大约20年前，我在杂志上读到这篇文章，塞达里斯说，人们总是走过来对我说，哦天哪，我爱你，你太棒了。
And I'm such a, you know, I just love you and Will, and Sedera says in the interview, and I usually say to them like, yeah, Will and I are having a lot of sexual problems. Which is so funny. Yeah, that is really funny. Oh, look at Bless, he's really having an issue. Bateman's really having, it's so fascinating
我是一个，你知道，我只是爱你和威尔，塞达里斯在采访中说，我通常会告诉他们，是的，威尔和我在性生活上有很多问题。这太搞笑了。是的，那真的很有趣。哦，看看Bless，他真的有问题。Bateman真的有，这太迷人了
that he's having microphone problems. Will, Sean, tell her what it's like when I have technical issues. It's not good. I'm going to slam the laptop in a second. What's wrong? We hear you great. We had McConaughey on once and he was in the blind
他有麦克风问题。威尔，Sean，告诉她当我遇到技术问题时是什么样子。那不好。我一会儿就要摔笔记本电脑了。怎么了？我们听得很清楚。我们曾经请过McConaughey，他在盲区
and Jason was having issues and it took 20 minutes and he got so mad and he was like fuck it and he started freaking out and McConaughey starts laughing with his camera covered. And Jason goes, oh, it's really funny, is it? Who's laughing? Who's laughing? That's not helpful. And he slammed his...
而Jason遇到了问题，花了20分钟，他变得非常生气，他说去他妈的，他开始抓狂，McConaughey开始笑，他的摄像头盖住了。Jason说，哦，这真的很有趣，是吗？谁在笑？谁在笑？那没用。他摔了他的……
And I slammed my laptop like a bitch. Wow. Yeah. It was not all right, all right, all right, is what you're saying. No. It was not all right, all right. Oh!
我像个婊子一样摔了我的笔记本电脑。哇。是的。那不是“没关系，没关系，没关系”，你是这个意思。不。那不是“没关系，没关系”。哦！
So Amy, how did you start in comedy? Yeah. Oh, believe me, we're getting into that. We're getting into that. Oh, right. So Amy, how did you start in comedy? Yeah. Oh, believe me, we're getting into that. We're getting into that. Oh, Lord, you guys with your questions, they're so good. First of all, your questions are always so good. Right? So sought out.
所以艾米，你是怎么开始从事喜剧的？是的。哦，相信我，我们要深入了解那个。我们要深入了解那个。哦，对了。所以艾米，你是怎么开始从事喜剧的？是的。哦，相信我，我们要深入了解那个。我们要深入了解那个。哦，天哪，你们的问题，它们太好了。首先，你们的问题总是那么好。对吧？所以很受欢迎。
We're up for, as you would call it, a Peabody. A Peabody. A Peabody. Amy, how was, can we talk about? Good reference. Can we, how was the, we talk about... Good reference. How was the... Was SNL 50 fun?
我们正在角逐，正如你所说的，皮博迪奖。皮博迪奖。皮博迪奖。艾米，怎么样，我们可以谈谈吗？很好的参考。我们可以，怎么样……很好的参考。怎么样……SNL 50有趣吗？
Because that show was great. Oh man, it was so fun. It was kind of... You were so great on it. It was kind of out of body. Like it was kind of too... It was almost too big. Like, like celeb fatigue almost.
因为那场演出很棒。哦天哪，太有趣了。它有点……你在上面表现得太棒了。它有点出窍。就像它有点太……它几乎太大了。就像，就像名人疲劳一样。
Yeah. But it was so fun. And I think it was a big success. Yeah, it was a great show. I started thinking about all the SUVs that must have been choking out midtown. Like how do they get... You want me to give you a scoop?
是的。但它太有趣了。而且我认为它非常成功。是的，那是一场很棒的演出。我开始想到所有那些一定在堵塞中城的SUV。它们是怎么……你想让我给你独家新闻吗？
You want me to give you a smartless scoop? Like a... Yeah. Making news. Breaking news. People had to share dressing rooms and I shared mine with Meryl Streep. Wow. How cool is that? Is she a dirty bathroom girl?
你想让我给你一个Smartless独家新闻吗？就像一个……是的。制造新闻。突发新闻。人们不得不共用更衣室，我和梅丽尔·斯特里普共用一个。哇。那有多酷？她是那种脏浴室女孩吗？
Does she keep the top off the toothpaste? Well, SNL, you don't have your own bathroom. You have like a, you know, it is a straight up, everyone uses like a hall bathroom. You don't have your own bathroom in your own dressing room at SNL. Do people still smoke back there? No, I didn't see anybody smoking. Maybe vaping, but yeah. But yeah, maybe you could. Do people still smoke back there? No, I didn't see anybody smoking. Just Dave Chappelle. Maybe vaping, but yeah.
她会把牙膏盖子不盖上吗？嗯，SNL，你没有自己的浴室。你有一个，你知道，它是一个直截了当的，每个人都用像大厅浴室那样的。你在SNL的更衣室里没有自己的浴室。人们还在后面抽烟吗？不，我没看到任何人抽烟。也许在抽电子烟，但是的。但是的，也许你可以。人们还在后面抽烟吗？不，我没看到任何人抽烟。只有戴夫·查普尔。也许在抽电子烟，但是的。
But yeah, maybe you could if you just did it. I bet no one would stop you. Was she a good dressing room partner? The loveliest. We were kind of two ships, but I took a picture of the door because it was nice to have my... I love that sketch she did.
但是的，也许如果你只是做了，你可以。我敢打赌没人会阻止你。她是一个好的更衣室伙伴吗？最可爱的。我们就像两艘船，但我拍了一张门的照片，因为它很高兴有我的……我喜欢她做的那个小品。
I know, so funny. Her and Kate, Kate is so... I mean, could she have hiked those jeans up higher? I mean, it was just tough. Just tough. But it was so fun. It felt like a high school reunion. Everybody regressed a little bit back into their old roles.
我知道，太搞笑了。她和凯特，凯特太……我的意思是，她能把牛仔裤提得更高吗？我的意思是，那真是太难了。太难了。但它太有趣了。感觉就像高中同学聚会。每个人都稍微退回到了他们以前的角色。
Isn't that fun? And it was fun. It was, you know, I can't believe I was there, to be very honest. Like, it was wild. You and Tina were great in your bit. Yeah, you and Tina, I loved it. That was a great bit. It was, you know, I can't believe I was there, to be very honest. Like it was wild. You and Tina were great in your bit. Yeah, you and Tina, I loved it. That was amazing. That was a great bit.
那不是很有趣吗？而且它很有趣。它，你知道，我简直不敢相信我在那里，说实话。就像，它太疯狂了。你和蒂娜在你们的片段里表现得很棒。是的，你和蒂娜，我喜欢它。那是一个很棒的片段。它，你知道，我简直不敢相信我在那里，说实话。就像它太疯狂了。你和蒂娜在你们的片段里表现得很棒。是的，你和蒂娜，我喜欢它。那太棒了。那是一个很棒的片段。
That was so good. Thanks. For Tracy Tina Fey. So listen, Amy, when you... Yeah, I think she's fucking... Tracy's got it, bro. Sean, you treat Tracy like she's getting dumber. I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding. Amy, tell a little bit, wait, just you guys,
那太好了。谢谢。为了Tracy Tina Fey。所以听着，艾米，当你……是的，我想她他妈的……Tracy做到了，兄弟。Sean，你对待Tracy就像她越来越笨一样。我开玩笑的，我开玩笑的，我开玩笑的。艾米，讲一点，等等，只是你们，
and then you and Maya did Bronx Beat, which is an all time favorite. Hilarious. Can you tell, these guys probably don't know where Bronx Beat came from, the origin story of it. Oh yeah, the story of that is there's an amazing the head of the hair department, Jody Mancuso, is from the Bronx and she has that accent
然后你和Maya做了Bronx Beat，这是史上最爱。太搞笑了。你能讲讲，这些家伙可能不知道Bronx Beat是从哪里来的，它的起源故事。哦是的，那个故事是有一个很棒的头发部门主管，Jody Mancuso，她是布朗克斯人，她有那种口音
and she would just work with us in the hair and makeup room and we just started talking like her. So there's a real Jodi, so when we do the show we always go into the hair room and just have Jodi be like our vocal dialect coach. Yeah, get us there. I love that. Have you ever thought about bringing her on the sketch?
她会和我们在发型和化妆室工作，我们只是开始像她那样说话。所以有一个真正的Jodi，所以当我们做节目时，我们总是去发型室，让Jodi成为我们的发音教练。是的，带我们去那里。我喜欢那个。你有没有想过让她上小品？
Yeah, but you know, it's funny that we brought Donna, the dresser, on for that moment. And those, the crew, like they're so, you know, real professionals like don't care about being on camera. Right. Yeah, yeah. Like a really actual good professional could give a shit if they're like an actor acting. Except for Wally.
是的，但你知道，有趣的是我们把Donna，服装师，带到了那一刻。而且那些，工作人员，就像他们太，你知道，真正的专业人士不在乎上镜。对。是的，是的。就像一个真正好的专业人士根本不在乎他们是否像个演员在演戏。除了Wally。
Wally loves it, Wally does love it. Wally loves it. Yeah, Wally the cute guy. The, Wally does love it. Wally loves it. Yeah, Wally the Cupid guy. The stage manager. But I said professional, I said professional. Exactly. But Amy, being back, doing that 50th like that, like you said, it's like a reunion.
Wally喜欢它，Wally确实喜欢它。Wally喜欢它。是的，Wally那个可爱的家伙。那个，Wally确实喜欢它。Wally喜欢它。是的，Wally那个丘比特家伙。舞台经理。但我说的是专业人士，我说的是专业人士。完全正确。但艾米，回到那里，做那个50周年纪念，像那样，就像你说的，就像一个聚会。
I think I asked you a long, long, long time ago when you departed the show and you decided to leave, that I was like, won't you miss like that? I thought you were kicked off. Sorry, I had a different. I was asked to leave. I was making people uncomfortable. That's why.
我想我在很久很久以前问过你，当你离开节目并决定离开时，我当时说，你不会想念那样的吗？我以为你是被踢出来的。抱歉，我有不同的。我被要求离开。我让人们感到不舒服。这就是原因。
You were given the opportunity to retire. Well, I had a very gentle HR meeting where a man in a suit put me on an elevator, Severin style, and I don't remember what happened since. Do they have an HR on the show? Because if so, that's got to be a really high-trafficked office. Well, they do. They do have an HR. And they do, like all of the shows that we've all worked on,
你被给予了退休的机会。嗯，我有一个非常温和的人力资源会议，一个穿西装的男人把我送上了电梯，Severin风格，我不记得之后发生了什么。他们在节目里有人力资源吗？因为如果是这样，那一定是一个人流量很大的办公室。嗯，他们有。他们确实有人力资源。而且他们确实，像我们所有人都工作过的所有节目一样，
you know, I mean, do you remember? And do we still have to go through the, you know, all that training every time, which is very good to do. But yeah, it is. I believe that they do that still, and should. It's probably a very different environment than I was there 20 plus years ago for all of us.
你知道，我的意思是，你还记得吗？我们是否仍然必须经历，你知道，每次都要进行所有那些培训，这很好。但是的，它是。我相信他们仍然这样做，而且应该这样做。这可能与我20多年前在那里时非常不同，对我们所有人来说。
But when you, like, you're one of the all-time greats to ever be on SNL. And it is true, it's true. I mean, everybody's great, but there's breakouts. I really like her style! Oh, somebody's trying to do that. She's a fan-tastic. What about the after party?
但当你，就像，你是SNL史上最伟大的人之一。而且这是真的，这是真的。我的意思是，每个人都很棒，但有突破。我真的很喜欢她的风格！哦，有人在尝试那样做。她太棒了。那庆功宴呢？
Was there a good, there must have been a very robust after party for this one. Yeah, robust after party at the Plaza Hotel. Whoa, was there an after-after with the little? There may have been, I didn't hang that long. I love bedtime. I used to be a vampire and now I love bedtime. I think about bedtime all day.
有一个好的，这次一定有一个非常热闹的庆功宴。是的，在广场酒店有热闹的庆功宴。哇，有带小东西的后续派对吗？可能有，我没待那么久。我喜欢睡觉。我曾经是个吸血鬼，现在我喜欢睡觉。我整天都在想睡觉。
Do they still do the little sort of, the size of like a fortune and a cookie, hand a little address for the after-after party? Is that still something that's done? I feel like one of the things that was different is things are texted and emailed, and I didn't have any of that when I was there wildly. We didn't even have phones
他们还在做那种，像饼干里的幸运签大小的，递一个小地址给后续派对吗？那还是现在做的事情吗？我觉得不同的一件事是事情是通过短信和电子邮件发送的，而我在那里时根本没有这些，太疯狂了。我们甚至没有手机
that we carried around on the floor. I mean, maybe we did occasionally, but we would kind of leave them in the dressing room, but now everything is texted. So I imagine maybe it's a text now. Maybe it's a Snapchat or some kind of YouTube channel people subscribe to. Maybe it's probably a podcast that tells you what we're the after-afters. You have to tune in.
我们随身携带在楼层上。我的意思是，也许我们偶尔会有，但我们会把它们留在更衣室里，但现在一切都是短信。所以我猜也许现在是短信了。也许是Snapchat或人们订阅的某种YouTube频道。也许可能是一个播客，告诉你后续派对在哪里。你必须收听。
Speaking of pods, you've got a new pod on, Amy. Oh my God, thank you so much for that. Tell us about your new pod. Oh, that's why she's here. Hi. Yeah, that's right she's here. That's right. Yeah, that's right. What's it called? And where can we find it?
说到播客，你有一个新播客，艾米。哦天哪，非常感谢你。告诉我们你的新播客。哦，这就是她在这里的原因。嗨。是的，没错，她在这里。没错。是的，没错。它叫什么？我们在哪里可以找到它？
Good Hang with Amy Poehler. It's called Good Hang, and it's on Spotify. Yes, can't wait. And I'm very excited. It's been really fun. We've been recording and getting ready for our launch. I don't know when this show is going to come on, when this one drops.
Good Hang with Amy Poehler。它叫Good Hang，在Spotify上。是的，等不及了。而且我非常兴奋。这真的很有趣。我们一直在录制并为我们的发布做准备。我不知道这个节目什么时候会播出，什么时候发布。
How far ahead are you guys? July of 2026. Okay, July 2026. So it's been going for about a year and it's been good. This is a good bump, this will be a good bump. Yeah. We'll be right back. And now back to the show.
你们提前了多少？2026年7月。好吧，2026年7月。所以它已经进行了大约一年了，而且很好。这是一个很好的推动，这将是一个很好的推动。是的。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。
But wait, but Amy, I was going to ask you if you ever wanted to do sketch comedy again because going back to what I was saying before, you're one of the all-time greats and it's hard to find people that can do what you do and Kristen Wiig does and Maya and Tina and all these really breakout people can do. And so, but every time I see you do it, I'm like,
但等等，但艾米，我本来想问你是否还想再做小品喜剧，因为回到我之前说的，你是史上最伟大的人之一，很难找到能做你所做的事情的人，Kristen Wiig能做，Maya和Tina以及所有这些真正突破的人都能做。所以，但每次我看到你做它，我就想，
ooh, I just wish you would go, like do more sketch. Because I fell in. But go back how? What do you mean? Do a sketch show? That's a lot of work. I know, but so you're like, ooh, it's nap time, bed time. It just feels like, I know what you mean, Shawn.
哦，我真希望你会去，比如做更多小品。因为我陷入了。但怎么回去？你是什么意思？做一个小品节目？那工作量太大了。我知道，但你就像，哦，是午睡时间，睡觉时间。这只是感觉，我知道你的意思，Sean。
I love doing it. I just don't know if I could launch back into an actual full-time sketch show. It's so much work. And creating the material, generating the material is so time consuming. But I love it. As a fan, I think I speak for a lot of people. Like, oh, we see you and everybody together.
我喜欢做它。我只是不知道我是否能重新投入到一个实际的全职小品节目中。那工作量太大了。而且创作材料，生成材料非常耗时。但我喜欢它。作为一个粉丝，我想我代表了很多人。比如，哦，我们看到你和大家在一起。
Well, we're not really taking questions from fans right now. But Amy, do you don't still do, you don't really still do like ask at her there's no version of that anymore. No improv. But you know, Tina and I have been on tour. We've been we've done our show a bunch of cities last year going back out again in March, April and May for you know, if you're in Orlando, do you have some dates you want to talk about? Yeah, we have Orlando, we have Detroit, Chicago, Boston, playing Red Rocks. Wow, no shit. Red Rocks. Yeah, we have Orlando, we have Detroit, we have Chicago, Boston, playing Red Rocks.
嗯，我们现在并没有真正接受粉丝的提问。但艾米，你不是仍然做，你不是真的仍然做像问她那样，没有那种版本了。没有即兴表演。但你知道，蒂娜和我在巡演。我们一直在，我们在去年去了很多城市，三月、四月和五月又要出去了，为了，你知道，如果你在奥兰多，你有什么想谈的日期吗？是的，我们有奥兰多，我们有底特律，芝加哥，波士顿，在Red Rocks演出。哇，不会吧。Red Rocks。是的，我们有奥兰多，我们有底特律，我们有芝加哥，波士顿，在Red Rocks演出。
Wow, no shit, Red Rocks. Yeah, yeah. That's cool. Is it written or is it improvised? Yeah, so it's written. It's like a long variety show. We have special guests come in. We kind of go through the history of our 30-year friendship.
哇，不会吧，Red Rocks。是的，是的。那很酷。它是写好的还是即兴的？是的，所以它是写好的。它就像一个长篇综艺节目。我们有特别嘉宾进来。我们回顾我们30年友谊的历史。
But there's a section in it that where we talk about Chicago and how we met and so we improvise there, which is really fun. Yes, I want to talk about that because I did Second City too and you did too. Yeah. And I never performed on the main stage, but you. Same.
但其中有一个部分，我们谈论芝加哥以及我们是如何认识的，所以我们在那里即兴发挥，这真的很有趣。是的，我想谈谈那个，因为我也做了Second City，你也做了。是的。而且我从来没有在主舞台上表演过，但你。一样。
Oh wow. So people think you're probably from Chicago all the time, but you're from Boston. Yeah, people think I'm from the Midwest a lot because also with Parks and Rec, their head goes to Indiana, so people think I'm from the Midwest a lot because also with Parks and Rec, their head goes to Indiana, so they think I'm like a Chicago. Would you consider yourself like a Boston homegirl?
哦哇。所以人们一直认为你可能来自芝加哥，但你来自波士顿。是的，人们认为我来自中西部很多，因为还有《公园与游憩》，他们的头脑去了印第安纳，所以人们认为我来自中西部很多，因为还有《公园与游憩》，他们的头脑去了印第安纳，所以他们认为我像个芝加哥人。你会认为自己像个波士顿本地女孩吗？
I mean, I'm definitely a homie. How is Bill Pola? Tell us how Bill Pola is. Let's talk about Bill. Can we talk about Bill for a minute? Oh God, he'd love it. So this is- He'd like us to talk for an hour.
我的意思是，我绝对是个本地人。Bill Pola怎么样？告诉我们Bill Pola怎么样。让我们谈谈Bill。我们可以谈谈Bill一分钟吗？哦天哪，他会喜欢的。所以这是——他会喜欢我们谈论一个小时。
This is, he would. So this is the reason I got Chadwick's and Brigham's mixed up. I just want to tell this story, if I could. We can always cut it, Aym, by the way, which is... We don't cut anything on this show. We went to... No, I can tell. There's no editing.
这是，他会。所以这就是我把Chadwick's和Brigham's搞混的原因。我只是想讲这个故事，如果可以的话。顺便说一句，我们总是可以剪掉它，Aym，这是……我们在这个节目上什么都不剪。我们去了……不，我可以讲。没有编辑。
This is super baggy. We go to Brigham's, which is an ice cream store in the mall in Burlington, Mass., which is where Amy's from, with her mom and dad. Well, with her dad. And there's this girl, she's like, I don't know, 17, working there as like her afternoon, weekend job, scooping ice cream. This is when Amy's first on SNL.
这超级宽松。我们去Brigham's，那是马萨诸塞州伯灵顿购物中心的一家冰淇淋店，那是艾米的老家，和她妈妈爸爸一起。嗯，和她爸爸一起。有个女孩，她大概，我不知道，17岁，在那里做下午、周末工作，挖冰淇淋。这是艾米第一次上SNL的时候。
And her dad goes, like, you know, 25 years, he goes, goes to the girl, just kind of silent, and he goes, you like your job? And she goes, she's like, scooping ice cream. She's like, yeah, I guess so. And he goes, you know who really likes her Jeff my daughter Teed himself up. It was so good
她爸爸去，就像，你知道，25年，他去，去那个女孩那里，只是有点沉默，他说，你喜欢你的工作吗？她说，她就像，挖冰淇淋。她说，是的，我想是吧。他说，你知道谁真的很喜欢她的Jeff我女儿Teed自己。这太好了
He will get on the elevator with people and say do you like TV and movies? Like like is anyone you're on the elevator with them We played golf. We played golf with these guys years ago, and Bill and I were playing with some random dudes, and he gets back in the car and he looks at me and he goes, Well, I told them. He can't help it. He's so proud though in the best way. I love that.
他会和人们一起上电梯，说你喜欢电视和电影吗？就像，就像任何你和他们在一起的人。我们打高尔夫。我们几年前和这些家伙打高尔夫，Bill和我正在和一些随机的家伙打球，他回到车里，他看着我，他说，嗯，我告诉他们了。他忍不住。但他以最好的方式感到骄傲。我喜欢那个。
My parents are like Boston strong, very proud. Retired teachers. Yeah, they watch every SNL, My parents are like Boston strong, very proud. Retired teachers. Yeah, they watch every SNL, they came to every early improv show I ever did live. They had a big watch party for me when our show launched in 1998 on Comedy Central, UCD. They just are very, very big fans.
我父母就像波士顿强人，非常骄傲。退休教师。是的，他们看每一集SNL，我父母就像波士顿强人，非常骄傲。退休教师。是的，他们看每一集SNL，他们参加了我曾经做过的每一个早期即兴表演。当我们的节目在1998年在喜剧中心，UCD推出时，他们为我举办了一个大型观看派对。他们只是非常，非常大的粉丝。
They're the definition of supportive parents. Like, what you do. Were they the ones that were the first funnies in your family for you? Like, is that where you got your humor from? Yeah, I think, well, I throw this back out to you guys because I think that you probably have families like this too.
他们是支持型父母的定义。就像，你所做的。他们是你们家里第一批让你觉得有趣的人吗？就像，那是你从哪里得到幽默感的吗？是的，我想，嗯，我把这个抛回给你们，因为我想你们可能也有这样的家庭。
You know, you have to kind of keep up. Like, for me, teasing is a love language. If I like you, I can tease you. And manners are kind of for people you don't know or you don't like. So the idea that you could bust each other was a way in which to sharpen your skills. And so we would tease each other.
你知道，你必须跟上。就像，对我来说，戏弄是一种爱的语言。如果我喜欢你，我可以戏弄你。而礼貌是给那些你不认识或不喜欢的人的。所以你可以互相打击的想法是一种磨练你技能的方式。所以我们会互相戏弄。
There was a lot of laughs at the table. It's very Boston Irish. And some families I learned as I went to college, are not that, which is always so shocking to me, when families don't get to poke each other. It's like, oh, okay, it's a different set of rules. You would often accuse, well, first of all, I would say when you say sitting around the table,
餐桌上有很多笑声。这非常波士顿爱尔兰风格。而且有些家庭我上大学时才知道，不是那样的，这对我来说总是那么令人震惊，当家庭不能互相戳对方时。就像，哦，好吧，这是一套不同的规则。你经常指责，嗯，首先，我会说当你谈论坐在桌子旁时，
let's be honest, it's sitting around the kitchen. Well, let's be honest, it's sitting around the kitchen. Well, let's be honest, it's sitting around the TV. It's sitting around the TV. It was sitting around the TV. But also, you would accuse me of playing too hard that Jason and I would play too hard. Yeah, well, you guys, you guys. It was his deep love, the love was too deep.
让我们诚实点，是坐在厨房旁。嗯，让我们诚实点，是坐在厨房旁。嗯，让我们诚实点，是坐在电视旁。是坐在电视旁。它是坐在电视旁。但同时，你会指责我玩得太狠，Jason和我玩得太狠。是的，好吧，你们，你们。这是他深沉的爱，爱太深了。
You know how they call things a love tap? You guys are a love shove. That's what it's called. You love shove. I love it. I love it. It's good. So it depends on the mood, you know? But I agree with you.
你知道他们怎么称呼事物为爱之轻拍吗？你们是爱之推搡。这就是它被称为的。你爱之推搡。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。这很好。所以这取决于心情，你知道吗？但我同意你的看法。
Like, you can meet people and there is that thing of like, if I'm not teasing you... Yeah, we talk about it all the time. I'm not interested in you. Then I'm not really interested. Yeah. Right. In a way.
就像，你可以遇见人们，有那种如果我不戏弄你……是的，我们一直在谈论它。我不对你感兴趣。那么我真的不感兴趣。是的。对。以某种方式。
Yeah, I mean, but some people have a higher and lower tolerance, like, you know, you have to just be a little gentle. But as far as your, I read too, Amy, that you say that you were parentified at a young age. I mean, that like you became your parents because your parents were so young when they had you. Yeah, my parents were young. And don't you feel that way?
是的，我的意思是，但有些人有更高和更低的容忍度，就像，你知道，你只需要稍微温柔一点。但至于你的，我也读到，艾米，你说你在年轻时就承担了父母的责任。我的意思是，就像你变成了你的父母，因为你父母生你时太年轻了。是的，我父母很年轻。你不觉得那样吗？
Like, I don't know, I don't know, but don't you feel, and this might be just our generation too, I don't know, but don't you feel, and this might be just our generation too, just feel like we felt very old really fast. Like we felt we had freedom, which gave us a sense of agency, and then we had jobs really early, and it just felt like we grew up fast.
就像，我不知道，我不知道，但你不觉得，这可能只是我们这一代人，我不知道，但你不觉得，这可能只是我们这一代人，只是觉得我们很快就变老了。就像我们觉得我们有自由，这给了我们一种代理感，然后我们很早就有了工作，这感觉就像我们成长得很快。
I don't know if that's a generational thing, but. Well, Jason, think about it, I'm not joking, was out working when he was, sweet little JB was working when he was seven. I know, bless. So cute, like with a little briefcase and a little security number. And a small mustache.
我不知道那是否是一代人的事情，但。嗯，Jason，想想看，我不是在开玩笑，他在他，甜蜜的小JB在七岁时就在工作了。我知道，保佑。太可爱了，就像带着一个小公文包和一个小安全号码。还有一小撮胡子。
So you guys, so you both, what I'm interested in, Amy, your background and your parents being school teachers and learning kind of from that, like what did you take from them for Archie and Abel? And Will, what did you take from your parents for Archie and Abel? And how do you do that together? Let me try to bundle that for you.
所以你们，所以你们两个，我感兴趣的是，艾米，你的背景和你父母是学校老师，从中学习，就像你从他们那里为Archie和Abel得到了什么？威尔，你从你父母那里为Archie和Abel得到了什么？你们是怎么一起做到的？让我试着为你打包那个。
Amy, do you parent like your parents at all? Oh, by the way, look who's talking. Oh yeah, no, I've been working on it. I've been working with a tutor. You've been working on bundling? Yeah, bundling is sort of a gathering term that he suggested I use internally, but now I'm spreading it. Yeah.
艾米，你像你父母一样养育孩子吗？哦，顺便说一句，看看谁在说话。哦是的，不，我一直在努力。我一直在和一个导师一起工作。你一直在努力打包？是的，打包是一个收集术语，他建议我在内部使用，但现在我正在传播它。是的。
That actually, you could sell a whole bunch of like a series of tapes. I'm just talking about bundling other people's questions. Let me bundle that for you. You could be so successful talking about bundling. If you jumped on a mini trampoline and did a cold dip at the same time, you'd be a bundle king. I think parenting is a constant, ever-changing thing.
那实际上，你可以卖一大堆像一系列磁带。我只是在谈论打包别人的问题。让我为你打包那个。如果你跳上迷你蹦床，同时做冷水浸泡，你就会成为打包之王。我认为育儿是一件不断变化的、不断变化的事情。
Somebody said this to me once that I always loved, which was, parenting is like a series of short stories. So a short story starts and you think, I don't know how this story is gonna go. I don't know the characters. I don't even know what's gonna happen. And then you're in the middle of the short story and you think, man, I never want this to end. I love this, I love this, I got it, I'm in the groove,
有人曾对我说了这样一句话，我一直很喜欢：为人父母就像是一系列短篇故事。一个短篇故事开始了，你心想，我不知道这个故事会怎么发展。我不认识这些角色。我甚至不知道会发生什么。然后当你身处故事中间时，你会想，天哪，我真希望它永远不要结束。我喜欢这个，我喜欢这个，我懂了，我进入状态了，
I know what I'm doing. And then the short story's over and you think, oh no, there's no way the next one could be better. It's just like a series of, your kid is changing so much and the world is changing so much and you have to stay kind of flexible, pliable, learn from your mistakes. Yeah.
我知道我在做什么。然后短篇故事结束了，你心想，噢不，下一个故事不可能比这个更好了。这就像是一系列……你的孩子在不断变化，世界也在不断变化，你必须保持灵活、变通，从错误中学习。是的。
I think the difference for me is, for my own parents is, I have to try really hard, Amy, you're really good at this, and you helped me do this in concert with you, to try to be, to remember to listen to what they're saying and to not try to impose what I think they, you need this, you need that, but to actually sit and listen
对我来说，与我父母的区别在于，我必须非常努力——艾米，你在这方面真的很擅长，你还帮我一起做到这一点——努力去记住倾听他们正在说的话，而不是试图强加我认为他们需要的，比如“你需要这个，你需要那个”，而是真正坐下来倾听
to what your kid is trying to say. Like, you know what I mean? Encourage them to, as much as they can to speak and to really hear, and it's not, I don't come by it naturally because that's not how I was raised. Do you know what I mean? Yeah, I am the same.
你的孩子试图表达什么。你知道我的意思吗？尽可能鼓励他们去表达，并真正去倾听，这对我来说并不自然，因为我不是那样长大的。你明白我的意思吗？是的，我也是一样。
It doesn't always feel natural. Your instinct is to want to give them advice or tell them what to be aware of or afraid of or share your own personal stuff. That's so instinctual, of course, because we want the best for our kids. And I remember reading somewhere that when your kid tells you something, you
这感觉并不总是自然的。你的本能是想给他们建议，或者告诉他们要注意什么、害怕什么，或者分享你自己的个人经历。这太本能了，当然，因为我们想给孩子最好的。我记得在哪里读到过，当你的孩子告诉你某件事时，你
just repeat it back to them like you're doing a headline of a news story. It actually works really well with people too. I bet it happens on this podcast too. They say, oh, I had a bad day in math. And then you go, you had a bad day in math. That's all you say. Period. Yeah. I mean, I'm usually thinking about what the bit is. Like, you know what I mean? But no, but you're right, you're right. And the other day, again, we were talking about something with one of our kids and Amy and I were talking on the phone and I said, oh, I identify with that and I think that my own experience,
只需像播报新闻头条一样重复给他们听。这对成年人也同样有效。我敢说这个播客里也会发生这种情况。他们说，“噢，我数学课过得很糟糕。”然后你说，“你数学课过得很糟糕。”你只需要说这些。句号。是的。我是说，我通常在想接下来的梗是什么。你知道我的意思吗？但你说得对，你说得对。前几天，我们又在和其中一个孩子谈论某件事，我和艾米在电话里聊，我说，“噢，我对此很有共鸣，我想我自己的经历……”
and you said to me, you're like, they don't really wanna hear about your experience. They want you to listen to theirs. Yeah, yeah. And don't you feel like this happens as. Yeah, yeah. And we all, this happened, don't you feel like this happens as adults too, when someone talks about like, well, when I used to, you're just like, oh boy.
然后你对我说，你就像是说，他们其实不想听你的经历。他们想让你倾听他们的。是的，是的。你不觉得这在成年人之间也会发生吗？是的，是的。我们都……这发生了，你不觉得这在成年人之间也会发生吗？当有人谈论“嗯，当我过去……”时，你只会觉得，“噢，天哪。”
You know, even in your 50s, it still happens where someone talks about, well, I, you know, in the business I used to be in, we would be able, and you're like, well, that's not the way it is anymore, old man. Right, right, right. It's not that you don't understand. Like, it's so- Yeah, Jason, you must get old man. Right, right. It's not that you don't understand. Yeah, Jason, you must get old man a lot, right?
你知道，即使到了50多岁，这种情况依然会发生，有人谈论“嗯，我，你知道，在我以前从事的行业里，我们能够……”，然后你心想，“好吧，老兄，现在已经不是那样了。”对，对，对。并不是你不理解。这太……是的，杰森，你一定经常被叫“老头子”吧？对，对。并不是你不理解。是的，杰森，你一定经常被叫“老头子”吧？
Yeah, I do a lot more recently. It's pretty shocking. Yeah, I find that it's, I'm constantly battling, like, how much should I be leading this parenting thing, or how much should I be reacting to this parenting thing? In other words, like, should I be waiting to see what thing? In other words, should I be waiting to see
是的，最近确实多了很多。这挺令人震惊的。是的，我发现我一直在纠结，比如，我应该在育儿这件事上引导多少，或者我应该对这件事做出多少反应？换句话说，比如，我是应该等着看……换句话说，我是应该等着看
what they need me to parent them at or should I initiate sort of parenting based on nothing they're actually showing me? In other words, should I wait to see until how they react to a certain situation and then talk to them about that? Or this could use a bundle. Yeah, we could bundle this.
他们需要我在哪方面引导他们，还是应该在他们没有表现出任何需求的情况下主动进行某种引导？换句话说，我是应该等到看他们对某种情况有何反应，然后再和他们谈论吗？或者这可以打包处理。是的，我们可以打包处理。
Are we still rolling? Could we go back to one? What I think what you're trying to say, yeah. Amy, tell Or this could use a bundle. Yeah, we could bundle this. Are we still rolling? Can we go back to one? What I think what you're trying to say, yeah. Amy, tell, Amy. Let's bundle, let's bundle. Hey, wait, Amy, try to guess what he's trying to say, please. I think the bundle here is how can I be best of service
我们还在录吗？能回到第一点吗？我想你试图表达的是，是的。艾米，告诉……或者这可以打包处理。是的，我们可以打包处理。我们还在录吗？能回到第一点吗？我想你试图表达的是，是的。艾米，告诉，艾米。打包吧，打包吧。嘿，等等，艾米，请试着猜猜他想说什么。我想这里的“打包”是指我该如何最好地服务
to my kids. Yes. Thank you. When they're teens, yeah, that's the bundle. That's so good. That's the bundle. But you know, I read something, and by read something, I mean I saw it on TikTok.
我的孩子们。是的。谢谢。当他们是青少年时，是的，这就是“打包”。太棒了。这就是“打包”。但你知道，我读到过一些东西，我说的“读到”是指我在TikTok上看到的。
Right. There, supposedly when your kids become teens, you go from producer to consultant. That's the difference. You're no longer producing their lives, you're there for them to consult. So you have to kind of let them start producing their own lives, which is not easy.
对。据说当你的孩子进入青春期时，你就从“制片人”变成了“顾问”。这就是区别。你不再为他们的生活制作内容，你只是作为顾问存在。所以你必须让他们开始制作自己的生活，这并不容易。
Not easy. Perfect use of the bundling concept, right? And I've also heard that, you know, part of, like I've heard you love therapy as much as I love therapy. I can talk about it all day long. I love it. I love going to therapy. And because you...
不容易。对“打包”概念的完美运用，对吧？而且我还听说，你知道，部分……我听说你像我一样热爱心理治疗。我可以整天谈论它。我爱它。我喜欢去心理治疗。因为你……
You go to therapy? Yeah. Are you serious? And I'm always trying to make her laugh and she's like, hey, let's get back on topic. But... She's so lucky to have you. You're so funny, Sean. I love you.
你去心理治疗？是的。你是认真的吗？我总是试图逗她笑，而她会说，“嘿，回到正题。”但是……她有你真是太幸运了。你太搞笑了，肖恩。我爱你。
Thanks, Annie. You're the funniest. You're the funniest. No, you're the funniest. And so, but you, I've heard, which means I saw on TikTok, that you identify as someone who's a natural fixer, or you want to get into action and problem solve,
谢谢，艾米。你才是最搞笑的。你才是最搞笑的。不，你才是最搞笑的。所以，但我听说——意思是说我在TikTok上看到的——你认为自己是一个天生的“修理者”，或者你想要采取行动去解决问题，
because that's kind of how I am a little bit. But as you've gotten older, that you've taught yourself how to pause and feel feelings and stuff like that. And how... Nearly. You got a lot of quotes out there. I do my research, I do my research.
因为我也有点像那样。但随着年龄增长，你学会了如何暂停，去感受情绪之类的。以及如何……差不多吧。你引用了很多名言。我做了研究，我做了研究。
You're talking out loud. You're really living out loud. I sent Sean a bunch of needlepoint pillows with a bunch of stuff on it. And Samian took credit for it. He's going to fill with pillows. I just regurgitate a whole conversation you had on your phone that I overheard. Know that how has that shaped you today?
你在大声说话。你真的活得很张扬。我送给肖恩一堆针织靠垫，上面写着一堆东西。然后萨米安把功劳揽在自己身上。他要用靠垫填满。我只是复述了你在电话里谈论的全部内容，我无意中听到的。知道那对你今天的塑造有什么影响吗？
Because I also read that the best work that you've ever done is the work where you feel most present. Yeah, I think improv was really helpful with that. You had to stay super present just to be, I mean, I imagine you guys feel that with this podcast too, right? Like you're actually where you are as opposed to being ahead or behind, which is really hard. Yeah, I'm still searching for that. Still every day trying to stay in the present moment.
因为我还读到过，你做过的最好的工作就是你感到最专注的工作。是的，我觉得即兴表演在这方面真的很有帮助。你必须保持超级专注，才能……我是说，我想你们在做这个播客时也有这种感觉，对吧？就像你真正身处当下，而不是超前或滞后，这真的很难。是的，我还在寻找那种状态。每天都在努力保持在当下。
It's not easy for me to not, you know, jump ahead. Will you talk to me about that? in the present moment. It's not easy for me, like, to not, you know, jump ahead. Yeah. Will you talk to me about that? Because I've always been told that, like, it's best to just stay in the present. But, like, my brain tells me... I know. But you go in there and your brain is like...
对我来说，不……你知道，不超前思考并不容易。你能跟我谈谈那个吗？在当下。对我来说，不……你知道，不超前思考并不容易。是的。你能跟我谈谈那个吗？因为我一直被告知，最好保持在当下。但是，我的大脑告诉我……我知道。但你进去之后，你的大脑就像是……
Like, I got plans, you know? And, like... Yeah. I've got plans. I've got a desire for the way I want this meeting to go or this That's so sweet, it's true you do you do going with that what do you but what are you supposed to do with that? What is that is that me inhaling a bomb inside your brain Yeah, it's just and then and then a little And then a little plan flies by like a bird like, pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa.
就像，“我有计划，你知道吗？”而且……是的。我有计划。我对自己希望这次会议如何进行有一种渴望，或者这次……这太可爱了，确实如此，你确实带着那个去，但你该拿那个怎么办？那是什么？那是我在你大脑里引爆了一颗炸弹吗？是的，它只是……然后……然后一个小计划像鸟儿一样飞过，啪啪啪啪啪啪。
Yeah. That's a little plan. So am I just supposed to react to things and not drive anything? I don't know. It's a great question actually. I don't know because I'm struggling with that all the time. How much can I be prepared because that calms me down. Preparation calms me down.
是的。那是一个小计划。所以我只是应该对事情做出反应，而不是去推动任何事情吗？我不知道。这其实是个好问题。我不知道，因为我一直在为此挣扎。我能做多少准备，因为那能让我冷静下来。准备工作让我冷静。
But, you know, life, you cannot control. You cannot control things in life. I mean, it's just like you have to let go. You know what's a perfect example of that, J.B., today? When I just told you I sprained my foot really bad last night, it was so painful, I can't even describe it. And I woke, and my old me would have been like, oh my God, I gotta cancel painful, I can't even describe it. And my old me would have been like, oh my God, I gotta cancel this, I can't do this,
但是，你知道，生活，你是无法控制的。你无法控制生活中的事情。我的意思是，你必须学会放手。你知道一个完美的例子吗，J.B.，今天？当我刚告诉你我昨晚脚扭得很严重，太疼了，我甚至无法形容。我醒来时，以前的我可能会想，“噢天哪，我得取消……”太疼了，我甚至无法形容。以前的我可能会想，“噢天哪，我得取消这个，我做不到，”
and I'm like, this is what it is right now, and I surrender to it, and I go, if I can't do this and I have to cancel that and I can't show up for it, then that's what it is. And it used to make me really depressed. I think that is one of the benefits I've been saying recently, I've been saying in therapy, that, oh, no applause.
而我现在想的是，“这就是目前的情况，”我顺从它，我说，“如果我做不到这个，我必须取消那个，我无法出席，”那这就是事实。这过去常让我非常沮丧。我认为这是我最近在心理治疗中提到的好处之一，噢，没有掌声。
I've been saying that- Oh, wait, Will, you're going, that's great. And you're 54. 54. Okay, very good. And what I've noticed at 54 is, and especially in the last six months, that it just kind of occurred to me,
我一直在说——噢，等等，威尔，你正在说，那太棒了。你54岁了。54岁。好的，非常好。我在54岁时注意到的是，特别是在过去六个月里，我突然意识到，
I'm like, oh, I'm doing a much better job of, this is what the situation is, and I'm realizing it in real time, and I'm not really in a panic about the outcome, I'm just accepting it for what it is. And I said this to you the other day, like I got this notion of like, feelings are gonna come, feelings aren't gonna kill you,, feelings aren't gonna kill you,
我心想，“噢，我在处理这种情况方面做得好多了，”我实时意识到这一点，我并没有对结果感到恐慌，我只是接受它本来的样子。前几天我跟你说过这个，就像我有了这样一个概念：情绪会来，情绪不会杀死你，情绪不会杀死你，
your feelings aren't gonna kill you. That's a big one. And it really, and I went, oh yeah. And I can let it, I can feel it, and then I can let it go. And I can recognize, I think I used to, you know, you'd freak out and then you'd think about it later.
你的情绪不会杀死你。这是一个大道理。它真的……我心想，“噢，是的。”我可以让它来，我可以感受它，然后我可以让它过去。我可以识别它，我想我过去常……你知道，你会惊慌失措，然后事后才去想它。
Now I can, in real time, go, oh, this is where I am. In a much better way than I, for me anyway, that I've ever been able to do. And I think that that's the benefit of being older, having experience, et cetera. I find my 50s to be my favorite decade by far. Yeah, yeah, it's pretty great. Oh really?
现在我可以实时地想，“噢，这就是我所处的状态。”这比我以前能做到的方式好多了，对我来说是这样。我认为这就是变老、拥有经验等等的好处。我发现50多岁是我迄今为止最喜欢的十年。是的，是的，这很棒。噢，真的吗？
As you get to your 60s, it's pretty cool. I'm having a great time. No. Yeah. What if you guys find out, you see Jason's license one of these days and you find out he's 62. I thought about that the other day.
当你到了60多岁，那也很酷。我过得很开心。不。是的。如果你们发现，哪天看到杰森的驾照，发现他62岁了怎么办？前几天我还在想那个。
No, Willie, I like what you said about like not being attached to the outcome. Maybe that's a good hack for me. It's like, it's okay to be prepared, but don't be like stuck on it has to end this way. Yeah, again, it's a new concept for me. I've just been kind of going through it and it's very freeing.
不，威利，我喜欢你说的关于“不执着于结果”的话。也许这对我是个好窍门。就像，做准备是可以的，但不要执着于“它必须以这种方式结束”。是的，再次强调，这对我来说是个新概念。我只是在经历它，这非常令人解脱。
Well, like Jason, for example, your mic hasn't been working this whole time and the audio hasn't recorded and you should be fine with that. Like just let that go. It's going to be great. It's a great episode and just let go of the outcome of that. Amy, any funny stuff happened on stage before with people?
嗯，比如杰森，你的麦克风一直没工作，音频也没录上，你应该对此没问题。就像，放手吧。这会很棒的。这是一期很棒的节目，放手对结果的执着吧。艾米，以前在舞台上发生过什么有趣的事吗？
Any funny stories? No, come on. Wait, Amy, why is 50 the best decade? I feel like I finally have a better sense of who I am. Kind of what we've been talking about. I have some of my priorities. I just feel like I'm a little kinder to myself. I definitely care less about how I'm perceived
有什么有趣的故事吗？不，得了吧。等等，艾米，为什么50岁是最好的十年？我觉得我终于对自己有了更好的了解。有点像我们一直在谈论的。我有了一些优先事项。我只是觉得我对自己更友善了。我绝对不在乎别人怎么看我，
by other people as long as I feel like my side of the street is clean. And I have a lot of wise people younger and older than me. Like I'm in this sandwich of experience. So I learn a lot from people younger and older than me. Like I'm in this sandwich of experience. So I learn a lot from people who are younger than me, and I learn a lot from people that are older than me, and knock on wood, I still feel healthy. Like being in your 50s,
只要我觉得我这边是清白的。而且我有很多比我年轻和年长的智者。就像我处于这种经验的夹层中。所以我从比我年轻和年长的人身上学到很多。就像我处于这种经验的夹层中。所以我从比我年轻的人身上学到很多，也从比我年长的人身上学到很多，谢天谢地，我依然感觉很健康。就像在50多岁时，
you're like the youngest old person you know. You're the youngest of the old people. You're the freshmen of old people. That's really true. And so we'll never be this young again in our 50s because I'm looking to people in their 60s and 70s to see how they're living life, how they're doing it, how they're keeping healthy.
你就像你认识的最年轻的老人。你是老人里最年轻的。你是老人的新生儿。这真的很真实。所以我们在50多岁时永远不会再这么年轻了，因为我看着60多岁和70多岁的人，看他们如何生活，如何做，如何保持健康。
And then I still feel connected to people in their 20s and 30s. It doesn't feel so far away. I'm on medication to reverse the aging process. Ooh, what are you doing? I'll text you. I'll send it in the chat. I'll send it in the chat. You're that guy who does all those crazy things to stay and aging process. Ooh, what are you doing? I'll text you, I'll send it into the chat. I'll send it into the chat. You're that guy who does all those crazy things to like stay and super shape.
然后我依然觉得和20多岁、30多岁的人有联系。感觉并不遥远。我正在服用药物来逆转衰老过程。噢，你在做什么？我会发短信给你。我会发在聊天里。我会发在聊天里。你就是那个为了保持……衰老过程而做所有疯狂事情的家伙。噢，你在做什么？我会发短信给你，我会发在聊天里。我会发在聊天里。你就是那个为了保持……超级身材而做所有疯狂事情的家伙。
Oh my God, remember that? Oh that too, yeah. Did you watch that? Oh my God, that's wild. Wait, Amy, remember when you used to come over and we would watch Intervention? Oh my God, yes, Sean. We would airplay all the instruments
噢天哪，还记得那个吗？噢那个也是，是的。你看过那个吗？噢天哪，太疯狂了。等等，艾米，还记得你过去常过来，我们一起看《干预》吗？噢天哪，是的，肖恩。我们会用空气弹奏所有乐器
in the opening theme. Great theme, Intervention, what a great show. I know that show made me so uneasy. I wanted to tell the story, or for you to tell the story about remember the time that you told your friend that the TV was voice activated? Oh my God. Have you told that story?
在开场主题曲里。很棒的主题曲，《干预》，多棒的节目。我知道那个节目让我很不舒服。我想讲那个故事，或者让你讲那个故事，关于你记得有一次你告诉你的朋友电视是声控的吗？噢天哪。你讲过那个故事吗？
I don't remember. Oh God. Well maybe, can I try to tell it? Yeah. Sean was with a bunch of friends, right? Yeah. Yeah, go ahead, Sean. No, no, I was just gonna help you out.
我不记得了。噢天哪。好吧，也许，我可以试着讲吗？是的。肖恩和一群朋友在一起，对吧？是的。是的，继续，肖恩。不，不，我只是想帮你一把。
And you guys were really like- We would get stoned after- Get really stoned. After an episode, after taping an episode of Will and Grace and we went back to his house one night. Will and Grace, that's the show you were on. That's it. That is, that is.
你们当时真的很……我们在……之后会嗑药——嗑得很嗨。在录制完一集《威尔和格蕾丝》之后，那天晚上我们回到了他家。《威尔和格蕾丝》，那是你参与的节目。就是那个。就是，就是。
Amy. You couldn't think of it? Yeah, Amy. Knock about our show. Never gonna get through it. This guy. A story that long will never make it on here. Go ahead, no, no, go ahead, don't tell it, it's good, it's really good.
艾米。你想不起来了？是的，艾米。别提我们的节目了。永远讲不完。这家伙。那么长的故事永远不会出现在这里。继续，不，不，继续，别讲了，这很好，真的很好。
Just bundle it. All right, well bundle it, bundle it. I'll try to bundle it. Okay, here we go. So we would go back after, we would get Stone, we'd just hang out and talk about the night and whatever after we tape an episode of Will and Grace. So we go to his house, it was a brand new house,
打包就行了。好吧，打包，打包。我会试着打包。好的，开始了。所以我们会在……之后回去，我们会嗑药，我们只是闲逛，谈论那个晚上，无论是在录制完一集《威尔和格蕾丝》之后。所以我们去他家，那是一栋全新的房子，
and he has a brand new house, he has a brand new media system, this massive screen in this screening room. And I'm high out of my mind, I can't even see straight, and he's trying, he goes, I just got the DVD of Castaway. We should watch it where the plane goes down because the effects are so cool, right? I'm like, yeah, let's put it on and watch it.
他有一栋全新的房子，他有一套全新的媒体系统，这个放映室里有巨大的屏幕。我当时嗨得不行，连路都看不清，他正试着，他说，“我刚拿到《荒岛余生》的DVD。我们应该看飞机坠毁的地方，因为特效太酷了，对吧？”我说，“是的，放出来看吧。”
So he walks all the way to the front of the screening room and I'm way in the back and I start to giggle. He's like, what's so funny? I'm like, nothing. And he can't get it to play and I go, is that a Sony? And he goes, yeah. And I go, well, those are the new ones. You don't even know what you have, you're so rich, right?
所以他一直走到放映室前面，我坐在最后面，我开始咯咯笑。他问，“什么这么好笑？”我说，“没什么。”他没法让它播放，我说，“那是索尼的吗？”他说，“是的。”我说，“嗯，那是新款的。你甚至不知道你拥有什么，你太有钱了，对吧？”
They're voice activated. And he goes, what? And I go, those are voice activated new screens. Like you have to speak the name of the movie into the DVD player. And he goes, you're making that up. That's not even true. I go, those are the new screens.
它们是声控的。他说，“什么？”我说，“那是新款声控屏幕。就像你必须对着DVD播放机说出电影的名字。”他说，“你在编造。那根本不是真的。”我说，“那是新款屏幕。”
You have to speak the name of the movie. and he totally bought it and he goes really close into the DVD player and he goes cast away And he looks at the screen and it didn't come up and the second time cast away And I couldn't believe. Me and Meredith Walker, we and Meredith Walker say cast away into our remote control a lot. No way. A lot. And into our DVD a lot. Cast away.
你必须说出电影的名字。他完全信了，他凑到DVD播放机前，说，“荒岛余生。”他看着屏幕，没反应，第二次，“荒岛余生。”我简直不敢相信。我和梅雷迪思·沃克，我们和梅雷迪思·沃克经常对着遥控器说“荒岛余生”。不会吧。经常。对着DVD也经常。荒岛余生。
Cast away. Oh, Meredith, let's say hi to Meredith. Hi, D. Hi, Meredith. Hi, D. Are you guys still working together? It's a friend of all of ours, Meredith Walker. Yes, yes. Is she still in Austin? Yep, living in Austin.
荒岛余生。噢，梅雷迪思，让我们向梅雷迪思问好。嗨，D。嗨，梅雷迪思。嗨，D。你们还在一起工作吗？那是我们共同的朋友，梅雷迪思·沃克。是的，是的。她还在奥斯汀吗？是的，住在奥斯汀。
Hey, oh, great. She's so great. We love Meredith. We love, love, love Meredith. Yeah, we say cast away quite a bit. Oh, that's great. I love telling someone something is voice activated when it isn't. I don't like a prank. I'm not a prank person at all.
嘿，噢，太棒了。她太棒了。我们爱梅雷迪思。我们爱，爱，爱梅雷迪思。是的，我们经常说“荒岛余生”。噢，那太棒了。我喜欢告诉别人某样东西是声控的，其实并不是。我不喜欢恶作剧。我根本不是那种喜欢恶作剧的人。
You got it. For anybody to use. But that is a harmless funny prank. That is harmless. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. Okay, so wait. Should I have any questions for Amy, your guest? It's okay, I mean, we don't need to.
你懂的。任何人都可以用。但那是一个无害的有趣恶作剧。那是无害的。我们马上回来。好的，回到节目。好的，等等。我应该问艾米，你的嘉宾，什么问题吗？没关系，我是说，我们不需要。
No, no, this is minute 46. I don't think we've had a legit one yet. I know, I've asked her a couple ones. Really? Yeah. Yeah, I mean we don't need to. No, no, this is minute 46, I don't think we've had a legit one yet. I know, I've asked her a couple ones. Really? Yeah. Yeah, I mean, do we really need to, I mean, we should probably. No, it's a conversation.
不，不，现在是第46分钟了。我觉得我们还没问过一个正经问题。我知道，我问过她几个了。真的吗？是的。是的，我是说，我们真的需要吗，我是说，我们可能应该……不，这是一场对话。
Yeah, it's a conversation. Wait, wait, I do want to get into, you touched on it before, talk a little bit about when you were in Chicago, AIM and how you knew your experience in Second City, who was in that, when you were on the tour, you toured with second city and improv Improv olympic Chicago all that stuff and then how you how that moved to New York and UCB and all that stuff
是的，这是一场对话。等等，等等，我确实想深入了解，你之前提到了，谈谈你在芝加哥的时候，艾米，以及你是如何了解你在“第二城市”的经历，谁在里面，当你巡演的时候，你和“第二城市”以及即兴奥林匹克芝加哥所有那些东西一起巡演，然后你是如何……那如何转移到纽约和UCB以及所有那些东西。
I'm just I mean it is I'll bundle it because it is important as a storyteller to discuss You will get kicked off this podcast if you Telling a story and I love crafting story and I love my story craft to be about telling crafts. Oh, God. So, get used to it. The only thing we like on this podcast more than independent film is talking about independent film. Go ahead, Amy. LAUGHS
我只是……我是说，这……我会打包，因为作为一个讲故事的人，讨论这个很重要。如果你讲故事，你会被踢出这个播客，我喜欢制作故事，我喜欢我的故事制作是关于讲述工艺的。噢，天哪。所以，习惯它吧。在这个播客上，我们除了独立电影之外，最喜欢的就是谈论独立电影。继续，艾米。（笑声）
Started out in Chicago and arrived at Second City in 93 and the seniors to my freshmen were, on the main stage of Chicago, Amy Sedaris, Steve Carell, Stephen Colbert. Amazing. Mike Myers and Chris Farley had just left to go to like Stardom at SNL. I rented Chris Farley's old apartment.
从芝加哥开始，93年到达“第二城市”，我的前辈是，在芝加哥主舞台上，艾米·塞达里斯、史蒂夫·卡瑞尔、斯蒂芬·科尔伯特。太棒了。迈克·迈尔斯和克里斯·法利刚离开去SNL成名。我租了克里斯·法利的老公寓。
In Chicago? In Chicago. I didn't know I was renting it, but you apartment. In Chicago? In Chicago. I didn't know I was renting it, but you know. In the Hancock building? No, it was another earlier one. Yeah, you know, back then in the 20s, when we were in our 20s and we moved every year, like remember moving every year.
在芝加哥？在芝加哥。我不知道我在租它，但你……公寓。在芝加哥？在芝加哥。我不知道我在租它，但你……在汉考克大厦？不，是另一个更早的。是的，你知道，那时候在20多岁，当我们20多岁时，我们每年都搬家，就像记得每年搬家吗？
Yes, that's true. And I think the apartment was probably like 390 a month and hard to make that rent. And then, yeah, studied and met Tina there very early on and met Rachel Dratch, who I was the understudy for at Second City. And it was just, the place was lousy with talent. Everyone was so great and then moved with, and then, and then UCB, Matt Besser, Matt Walsh, Ian Roberts, Ali Faranaki.
是的，那是真的。我想那公寓大概是390美元一个月，很难付得起房租。然后，是的，学习并很早就认识了蒂娜，认识了瑞秋·德拉彻，我在“第二城市”时是她的替补。那个地方到处都是人才。每个人都太棒了，然后搬到了……然后，然后是UCB，马特·贝瑟、马特·沃尔什、伊恩·罗伯茨、阿里·法拉纳基。
Oh, great guys, yes, yes, yes. Adam McKay, all those guys. Neil Flynn, they were all part of a big improv group called The Family that we would go and watch, and they were incredible. And then they also had UCB. I joined in 93, and then in 96, which is not that much time now that I think about it.
噢，很棒的家伙，是的，是的，是的。亚当·麦凯，所有那些家伙。尼尔·弗林，他们都是一个叫“家庭”的大型即兴表演团体的一部分，我们会去看，他们太不可思议了。然后他们也有UCB。我93年加入，然后96年，现在想来那没过多久。
It was only three years, but we left and moved to New York, drove to the city, did a show, and just started. Well, at the time it was, well, I don't want this to be uncomfortable for you, but I was dating Matt Besser at the time, so it was a different relationship. I knew it, I fucking knew it! Yeah.
才三年，但我们离开了，搬到了纽约，开车进城，做了一场演出，然后就开始了。嗯，当时是……嗯，我不想让你感到不舒服，但我当时在和马特·贝瑟约会，所以那是另一种关系。我知道，我他妈就知道！是的。
No, no, truly, I knew it. But here's the thing, here's a funny story and Amy knows this. So 96 and she knows how good I am with dates and this. Yeah, you're very good. 96 they come and they do UCB so it's Amy Walsh Besser and Ian and they do They do their show Bucket of Truth, which was an amazing show, it was so funny. It was a sketch show, improv and sketch, et cetera. And they're doing it downstairs at the West Bank on 42nd Street.
不，不，真的，我知道。但这里有一件事，这是一个有趣的故事，艾米知道。所以96年，她知道我记日期有多准。是的，你非常擅长。96年他们来了，做了UCB，所以是艾米、沃尔什、贝瑟和伊恩，他们做了……他们做了他们的演出《真理之桶》，那是一场精彩的演出，太搞笑了。那是一场小品秀，即兴表演和小品，等等。他们在42街的西岸剧院楼下演出。
And Peter Principato, the beloved Peter Principato, who we all love. Yeah, manager. My first agent. First agent. William Morris. And Peter Principato, and he was my agent at the time, and he said to me, hey, I've just signed
还有彼得·普林西帕托，我们都爱的亲爱的彼得·普林西帕托。是的，经理。我的第一个经纪人。第一个经纪人。威廉·莫里斯。还有彼得·普林西帕托，他当时是我的经纪人，他对我说了，嘿，我刚签了
this new comedy group, you've gotta go see them. They're performing at the time. And he said to me, hey, I've just signed this new comedy group. You've got to go see them. They're performing at the West Bank. So I went with Duff and Amy, I was dating Missy at the time. I don't know if I told you that. Oh, touche. You did, okay.
这个新的喜剧团体，你一定要去看他们。他们当时在表演。他说，嘿，我刚签了这个新的喜剧团体。你一定要去看他们。他们在西岸剧院表演。所以我带着达夫和艾米去了，我当时在和米西约会。我不知道我有没有告诉你。噢，触碰到了。你做到了，好的。
Yeah. So we go, the three of us to the West Bank, knowing nothing, go downstairs that little stage and watch them do Bucket of Truth and we're blown away. We go upstairs. You had not yet met Amy. Had not yet met.
是的。所以我们三个去了西岸剧院，什么都不知道，下到那个小舞台，看着他们表演《真理之桶》，我们被震撼了。我们上楼了。你还没见过艾米。还没见过。
We watched the show, we're blown away. We go for a drink after, we're talking about it. We talked about it for a few days because nobody was doing what they were doing. And we were like, God, that was so funny and it was so inventive and it was so cool and blah, blah, blah. So that is January of 1996.
我们看了演出，我们被震撼了。之后我们去喝了一杯，我们在谈论它。我们谈论了好几天，因为没人做他们正在做的事情。我们当时想，天哪，那太搞笑了，太有创意了，太酷了，等等等等。所以那是1996年1月。
And just like, what the fuck? Continue, sorry. Yeah, then we were there just slogging away and like Will said, and we remember this too, right? Like people had to come see you live. They had to go actually see you. We didn't have any, like, now you can really deep dive on someone really fast
就像，这他妈是怎么回事？继续，抱歉。是的，然后我们在那里只是辛苦工作，就像威尔说的，我们也记得这个，对吧？就像人们必须来看你们现场表演。他们必须亲自去看。我们没有任何……就像，现在你可以很快地深入了解某人
on the internet, but we didn't have that. So you had to like go see people live. What was that first space you guys had when you started? We had a, Solo Arts was the name of a, yeah, was like the walk-up theater where we would improvise there and stuff, so we just kind of slogged for a while in New York and handed out flyers in Washington Square Park and everyone, I was a waitress and just thinking like, okay, you know,
在互联网上，但我们没有那个。所以你必须亲自去看人们现场表演。你们刚开始时那个第一个空间是什么？我们有一个，Solo Arts是一个……的名字，是的，就像那个步入式剧院，我们在那里即兴表演之类的，所以我们在纽约辛苦了一段时间，在华盛顿广场公园发传单，每个人，我当时是个女服务员，只是想，好吧，你知道，
and then I started getting some bits on Conan because of Andy Richter and that's where I got like my SAG card, that's where I got my, you know, I got paid like an under five. And now you're in the building though, right? Like was it, could you like taste the possibility of SNL perhaps? Did you allow yourself to start to dream that?
然后我开始因为安迪·里希特在柯南节目上得到了一些片段，那就是我拿到演员工会卡的地方，那就是我……你知道，我拿到了像“五句台词以下”的报酬。但你现在在大楼里了，对吧？就像，你能尝到SNL的可能性吗？你允许自己开始梦想那个了吗？
Mm-hmm. That's such a good question. I think you're right. I didn't really put that together, but you're right. Like walking in a 30 rock, you are, I always feel like with jobs and stuff, like Chicago felt like where I was getting my training, but New York and Los Angeles, it's almost like,
嗯哼。那真是个好问题。我想你是对的。我没真的把那个联系起来，但你是对的。就像走进30号洛克菲勒中心，你……我总是觉得，对于工作之类的，芝加哥感觉像是我的训练地，但纽约和洛杉矶，这几乎就像，
you know when you're having like a pickup game of basketball and someone's just standing around and you're like, hey, come play. Like, your- Sure, don't say sure. Your proximity to the game can be very helpful. Like getting closer to the game, just being around. So that's what happened.
你知道当你进行一场篮球接球比赛时，有人只是站在旁边，你就像，“嘿，来玩吧。”就像，你的……当然，别说当然。你离比赛的距离可能非常有帮助。就像离比赛更近一点，只是在周围。所以这就是发生的事情。
When we moved to New York, we were just a little closer to the game. So we got asked to do things. And you're doing, and you're doing Bits on Conan and you did Andy's sister, Richter's sister, and you started doing more. And all those guys were there who were writers, a lot of whom were performers from Chicago.
当我们搬到纽约时，我们离比赛更近了一点。所以我们被要求做一些事情。你在做……你在柯南节目上做片段，你做了安迪的妹妹，里希特的妹妹，你开始做更多。所有那些家伙都在那里，他们是编剧，其中很多人是来自芝加哥的表演者。
You knew like McCann and Glazer and all those guys. Brian Stack, one of the all-time greats. And all those people, they're all there writing on Conan. And you guys are all kind of part of this group of people who are Creating comedy, right? Yeah, my decision to move to Chicago was probably the best decision For me in my career because it allowed me to meet all these people really fast who then went on to do things that I got To be a part of like I they remembered me for things. They put me in small things they, you know wrote things for me, and it was just this
你认识像麦肯和格雷泽所有那些家伙。布莱恩·斯塔克，史上最伟大的人之一。所有那些人，他们都在那里为柯南写稿。你们所有人都是这群人的一部分，在创造喜剧，对吧？是的，我搬到芝加哥的决定可能是我职业生涯中最好的决定，因为它让我很快认识了所有这些人，他们后来去做了一些我能参与的事情，比如他们记得我做过的事情。他们把我放在小事情里，他们，你知道，为我写东西，这只是当时
concentrated feeling of comedy at the time that then everybody went to LA and New York, and McKay was the head writer of SNL, and Tina got a job there. We all just started, it was really, really cool to, and I depended on the kindness of a lot of those people for a long time to have a job. Let me ask you a tough question,
一种集中的喜剧感觉，然后每个人都去了洛杉矶和纽约，麦凯是SNL的首席编剧，蒂娜在那里得到了一份工作。我们都开始……能……真的，真的很酷，而且我长期依赖很多人的善意才有一份工作。让我问你一个棘手的问题，
and I'll try to bundle here. Basically, it's basically after all of the accomplishment, you've just walked us through the whole beginning and everything, it just seems like you've done, or maybe even far exceeded, what you allowed yourself to dream of at that age when you were starting. What's left? What would you love to do in your next,
我会试着在这里打包。基本上，在所有的成就之后，你刚刚带我们走过了整个开始和一切，看起来你已经做了，或者甚至远远超过了，你在那个年龄开始时允许自己梦想的事情。还剩下什么？你接下来想做什么，
you know, now that you're a freshman? Why do you still get out of bed, Amy? What do you want? Yeah, I mean, you've done it. You've had this incredible career already and you're still, as you said, a freshman. Like, where would you love, how would you like to use what you've done,
你知道，既然你是个新生？你为什么还要起床，艾米？你想要什么？是的，我是说，你已经做到了。你已经有了这段不可思议的职业生涯，而且你仍然，正如你所说，是个新生。就像，你想要在哪里，你想要如何利用你所做的，
the success you've had? Bundle, bundle. Yeah, sorry, go ahead. Well, that would you like to use what you've done, the success you've had? Bundle. Yeah, sorry, go ahead. Well, I am, that's why I'm starting to wind down and this podcast is the beginning of that. Like, I'm just starting to wind down away from showbiz. Hang on a second, hey, truly? Yeah, yeah.
你所取得的成功？打包，打包。是的，抱歉，继续。嗯，我正在……这就是为什么我开始放慢脚步，这个播客就是那个的开始。就像，我只是开始远离演艺圈。等一下，嘿，真的吗？是的，是的。
Fucking cool. Just to be cool. Are you being weird or no? No, no, no, we're the number two most downloaded podcast on the planet, so just know your gent. No, no, her podcast she's talking about. Oh yeah, that is a wind down, you're right. That is a wind down.
他妈的酷。只是为了酷。你在装怪还是没有？不，不，不，我们是地球上下载量第二多的播客，所以只要知道你的……不，不，她说的是她的播客。噢是的，那是一个放慢脚步，你是对的。那是一个放慢脚步。
No, or are you talking about us? Well, you know what? It remains to be seen. It remains to be seen. But no, no, but honestly, it is kind of why I'm excited to do a podcast, because I'm actually, Jason, to genuinely answer your question,
不，还是你在说我们？嗯，你知道吗？还有待观察。还有待观察。但没有，没有，但老实说，这确实是我为什么很高兴做播客的原因，因为我实际上，杰森，为了真诚地回答你的问题，
I am excited about what is the next, I like thinking about what is the next thing to do. Like I like trying new things, that's what keeps me feeling engaged in the world and in our creative. So I'm very excited about this new podcast because I really like, I'm a huge fan of podcasts in general. I listen to them all the time and they really replaced a lot of like media for me and I'm into the idea of exploring it
我对接下来是什么感到兴奋，我喜欢思考接下来要做什么。就像我喜欢尝试新事物，这就是让我感到与世界和我们的创意保持联系的原因。所以我对这个新播客感到非常兴奋，因为我真的很喜欢……我总体上是播客的超级粉丝。我一直听它们，它们确实取代了我很多媒体，我对探索它的想法很感兴趣，
because I really like talking to people and I'm curious about people and I learn a lot about myself and I like to have fun. I think what's happened in the space, especially for women, is that women are being asked to be teachers and wise leaders and they don't get to fuck around and do very little research like you guys. You know that?
因为我真的很喜欢和人交谈，我对人很好奇，我对自己了解很多，而且我喜欢玩得开心。我认为在这个领域发生的事情，特别是对女性来说，是女性被要求成为老师和智慧的领导者，她们不能像你们一样胡闹和做很少的研究。你知道吗？
You guys do not know who the guest is, which is the wildest con in the world. It's unbelievable. By the way, you could have bundled that insult. That would have been a lot nicer. But let me ask you a tough question. You know, Sean, shut up for one second. Shut the fuck up.
你们不知道嘉宾是谁，这是世界上最疯狂的骗局。这简直不可思议。顺便说一句，你本可以把那个侮辱打包的。那会好得多。但让我问你一个棘手的问题。你知道，肖恩，闭嘴一秒钟。他妈的闭嘴。
Fuck. Amy, Amy, answer this question honestly. This is a tough one. This is a hard hitting, all right? And I know you're very serious for a comedian, so that's okay. Her mom used to say that to her when they get into arguments. When we get in a fight, she'd say, you're so serious for a comedian. So, wait, have you ever listened to Smartless?
操。艾米，艾米，诚实地回答这个问题。这是一个棘手的问题。这是一个硬核的，好吗？我知道你作为一个喜剧演员非常严肃，所以没关系。她妈妈过去常在她和他们争吵时对她说。当我们吵架时，她会说，“作为一个喜剧演员，你太严肃了。”所以，等等，你听过《Smartless》吗？
Of course I have. Okay, you have. That's a little high. I've listened to Smartless. She could go up on that. I'm pretty sure, what are you talking about? Of course I have, oh my God, I love, my favorite episode is the one with the lady
我当然听过。好的，你听过。那有点高。我听过《Smartless》。她可以上去。我非常确定，你在说什么？我当然听过，噢天哪，我爱，我最喜欢的一集是那个女士
and the other one with the guy. I love the one with the guy. Oh my God. Oh, I like the one with the Bradley. But so, in your answer to my unbundled question, it sort of gets into the area of there is a slight plan, but you still want to kind of stay in the present and not be too sort of strategic about what the next five, ten years are, right?
和那个男人的那一集。我喜欢那个男人的那一集。噢天哪。噢，我喜欢布拉德利的那一集。但所以，在你回答我未打包的问题时，它有点进入了这样一个领域：有一个轻微的计划，但你仍然想保持在当下，而不是对未来五、十年有什么战略性，对吧？
So like, how do you find the balance there? I guess it's just figuring out, it's just kind of figuring out So like, how do you find the balance there? I guess it's just figuring out, it's just kind of figuring out what feels challenging. I like a challenge. So I like mixing things up to feel challenging. And also a big part of my 50s has been balancing my relationship to work in general and how do I make sure that there's real balance in my life.
所以，你是如何找到平衡的？我想这只是弄清楚，这只是有点弄清楚……所以，你是如何找到平衡的？我想这只是弄清楚，这只是有点弄清楚什么感觉具有挑战性。我喜欢挑战。所以我喜欢把事情混合起来，感觉具有挑战性。而且我50多岁的一个重要部分是平衡我与工作的关系，以及我如何确保我的生活中确实有平衡。
Like the last five years you guys were talking about being on your podcast. Stuff that's not challenging potentially, right? Exactly. Just relaxing, yeah. Yes, like basically how to find ease and enjoy, the past five years have been wild. Wild.
就像过去五年你们谈论在你们的播客上。可能没有挑战性的事情，对吧？正是。只是放松，是的。是的，就像基本上如何找到轻松和享受，过去五年太疯狂了。疯狂。
And you know, what you guys do here, what I've been doing is just like trying to just genuinely laugh with my friends. It's been actually, you know, how I've been keeping sane. And so I want to just do whatever feels like that, which feels kind of fun and a little bit challenging. And so I'm always trying to figure it out. I don't know, it's a long-winded answer.
而且你知道，你们在这里做的事情，我一直在做的事情，就像试图真诚地和我的朋友们大笑。这实际上是，你知道，我如何保持理智的。所以我只想做任何感觉像那样的事情，感觉既有趣又有点挑战性。所以我一直在试图弄清楚。我不知道，这是一个冗长的回答。
I don't know. No, but it makes total sense. It's basically a combination of all the things. And you're able to combine now because you're older and smarter and wiser and it doesn't have to be like all go on career or all go on just like no, fuck it, I don't want to do anything.
我不知道。不，但这完全说得通。这基本上是所有事情的结合。你现在能够结合，因为你更老、更聪明、更睿智，而且不必像……全部投入事业，或者全部投入……不，去他的，我什么都不想做。
We're actually able to merge both now, finally, at this age, I think. And women, I think, especially, have often a burden to really pay attention to what everybody is doing and feeling, and then if you have the luxury of turning it around and trying to figure out yourself, it's like, that is what can be great about getting older
我们实际上能够合并两者，终于，在这个年龄，我想。而且女性，我想，特别是，经常有一种负担，要真正注意每个人在做什么和感受什么，然后如果你有奢侈的时间把它转过来，试着弄清楚你自己，就像，这就是变老的好处，
and women do really well, I think, when they give themselves time to do that. Let me speak to that. Let me speak about women. Yeah, let's talk about women. So. But we'll go ahead. Your thoughts on women?
而且女性确实做得很好，我想，当她们给自己时间去做那个时。让我谈谈那个。让我谈谈女性。是的，让我们谈谈女性。所以。但我们会继续。你对女性的看法？
Ha ha ha ha. But Amy, who is that person that you bounce stuff off of or when you get like? I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie.
哈哈哈哈。但艾米，谁是那个你把事情反弹给的人，或者当你变得像……我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。
I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie.
我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎。
I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie. have been through it with me, I think, is really the biggest resource for me. You know, people who have kids and people who, you know, who understand what it's like to feel overwhelmed and stuff, and especially the past five years, which has just been a complete insane hit after hit of sci-fi nightmares.
我不撒谎。我不撒谎。我不撒谎。我不撒谎。我不撒谎。我不撒谎。我不撒谎。我觉得那些陪我走过这段路的人，真的是我最大的资源。你知道，那些有孩子的人，那些了解那种不知所措的感觉的人，尤其是过去这五年，简直就是一场接一场疯狂的科幻噩梦。
Right. That's a dream of mine. Totally. But what, what's it like, what's it like being for you and Will being on the verge of being empty nesters? It's not the verge, but it's gonna, it's gonna come sooner than later. Do you think about that? And like. I do.
对。那是我的一个梦想。完全是。但是，你和威尔即将成为空巢老人，那是什么感觉？虽然还没到那个临界点，但迟早会来的。你会想这件事吗？比如。我会。
How that relates to what you're gonna do? I know. I know, I haven't really, but kind of in the short story metaphor, I haven't, I'm like, I don't feel like the the story that I'm there yet. So yeah quite yeah, I don't know I mean, it's it feels so It's I don't even know it's yeah, I got one about to go to college and it's how does it feel? It's bleak, you know, because there's just it it it there. It's so it's a mortality thing
这和你接下来要做的事情有什么关系？我知道。我知道，我还没真正想过，但用短篇小说的比喻来说，我还没到那个阶段。所以，是的，我不知道，我的意思是，这感觉太……我甚至不知道，是的，我有一个孩子快要上大学了，感觉如何？很凄凉，你知道，因为那种感觉……这是一种关于死亡的事情。
It's like it's you know, we know, we all kick it down the road. Oh, it's about you. Well, but it's like, it's the concept of the end of something that is just something is conveniently kind of pushed aside, and then it's here. Can I say something about that that I've noticed? And this is, JB, I've learned from you something that,
就像是，你知道，我们都知道，我们都在拖延。哦，这是关于你的。嗯，但这就像是，某种事物的终结这个概念，通常会被方便地搁置一旁，然后它就真的来了。关于这一点，我能说点我注意到的事情吗？这是我从你身上学到的，JB，
and I mean this gently and I mean this sweetly, which is- This is gonna hurt. No, which is, you've been, Jason's been so nervous and anxious about Franny going to college for a few years and he's talked about it. And so I see him going through the pain for so long
我是温和且善意地提出来的，那就是——这会很伤人。不，那就是，杰森，你几年来一直对弗兰妮上大学感到非常紧张和焦虑，你也谈到过这一点。所以我看到你经历了这么长时间的痛苦。
and this is an example of not living in the present. So sometimes I think that you had a tough time enjoying the moment because you're just so, you've been anticipating for years, you've been putting that out and talking about it. And I'm trying to separate myself from her so it doesn't hurt. Yeah, exactly. Which is by the way, which is so you like, remember you do that. Like Jason's thing to not laugh when he's in a take is to think about people dying in a car crash. I'm not kidding. And then he doesn't. And then he won't go up. Right?
这就是不活在当下的一个例子。所以我有时认为你很难享受当下，因为你太……你已经预料了这么多年，你一直在表达并谈论它。而我正试图让自己与她保持距离，这样就不会那么痛了。是的，没错。顺便说一句，这很像你，记得你这样做过吗？比如杰森在拍摄时为了不笑，会去想人们在车祸中丧生。我没开玩笑。然后他就不会笑了。然后他就不会搞砸了。对吧？
Well, we all know. We all do that. We all know Jason is sociopathic to this. No, he's a robot. But the thing is, but I see that in you and I've said it to you before, I'm like, it's okay, let that moment come when that moment comes and enjoy. So I've been using it, I keep reminding myself, just enjoy it now, enjoy it now.
嗯，我们都知道。我们都这样做。我们都知道杰森在这方面是个反社会者。不，他是个机器人。但问题是，我在你身上看到了这一点，我以前也对你说过，我说，没关系，让那一刻在它到来的时候到来，去享受它。所以我一直在用这个方法，我不断提醒自己，现在就享受它，现在就享受它。
It's, again, not easy. It is not easy. No. It's a great no. Well, raise your hand if you think you're gonna live to 100 and if you wanna live to 100. That's me. Okay, three of us are raising our hands. Sean is not raising, it's that ankle.
这，再说一次，不容易。这真的不容易。不。这太棒了，不。好吧，如果你认为你能活到100岁，并且你想活到100岁，请举手。那就是我。好吧，我们三个人举手了。肖恩没举手，是因为那个脚踝。
Sean's like, I can't go on with that ankle. I can't, with this ankle, no way. No, I'm done. The ankle was the last straw. I think we got a shot. Yeah, no, it's really, didn't one of these really smart scientists lately say that the person that's going to live to 120 or 150 or something
肖恩说，我带着这个脚踝可活不下去。我带着这个脚踝，没门。不，我受够了。脚踝是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。我觉得我们有希望。是的，不，真的，最近不是有位非常聪明的科学家说，那个能活到120岁或150岁的人
is already born? Like that's gonna be kinda common in this generation. Like 100 is like the new 80s. Yeah, but what kind of life do you have at 120? Yeah, Sean, I hear you. Like as long as it feels like a fruitful life. But you know, imagine if you were like a little dude in a cute little suit.
已经出生了吗？就像这在这一代人中会变得很普遍。比如100岁就像新的80岁。是的，但你120岁时过的是什么样的生活？是的，肖恩，我明白你的意思。只要感觉生活充实就行。但你知道，想象一下如果你像个穿着可爱小西装的小家伙。
And you got wheeled around. Like in the news, like the local news, they cut to like, Marjorie is 106 today, and we visited her, and she can't talk or move. And they're like, Marjorie, Marjorie, what advice do you have for people to live this long? And she's like, make sure that you're here. And she's got cake falling out of her mouth.
然后你被推着到处走。就像在新闻里，比如当地新闻，他们切到画面说，玛乔丽今天106岁了，我们拜访了她，她不能说话也不能动。他们问，玛乔丽，玛乔丽，你对人们长寿有什么建议吗？然后她说，确保你还活着。而且她嘴里还掉着蛋糕。
Every day. Yeah, exactly. Please walk in, have a glass of wine and... Exactly, I don't want to be that. I don't want to be Marjorie. Remember Ernest Borgnein had that great, he had this great advice on how to live forever, which was to snap one off every day. Oh, he did? Yeah, and you know where he lived?
每天。是的，没错。请走进来，喝杯红酒，然后……没错，我不想那样。我不想成为玛乔丽。记得欧内斯特·博格宁有个很棒的建议，关于如何长生不老，那就是每天都要“来一发”。哦，他真的这么说？是的，你知道他住在哪里吗？
In Jason and Amanda's house. And so I always reminded him to think about Ernest Borgnein walking around that house. Just throwing goo all over the place. He had Borgnein lives actually. Oh, nice, very nice. Beautiful. Thanks guys.
在杰森和阿曼达的房子里。所以我总是提醒他去想欧内斯特·博格宁在那栋房子里走来走去。到处乱扔粘液。他真的住过博格宁的房子。哦，不错，非常好。太美了。谢谢你们。
Amy, I have one last comment before we let you go because we've had you for too long and I want to thank you for your time. Thank you, Sean. I told you, and both you and Will, I love Archie and Abel so much and I love Maple and Franny too. Everybody on this podcast right now.
艾米，在你离开之前我还有一个最后的评论，因为我们占用你太久了，我想感谢你抽出时间。谢谢你，肖恩。我告诉过你，你和威尔，我非常爱阿奇和阿贝尔，我也爱梅普尔和弗兰妮。此时此刻播客里的每一个人。
You guys have done such a phenomenal job between your journey between you two, your kids are just unbelievable, great human beings. And it's the greatest compliment to you guys. I just love them and you guys. And I wanted to remind people to listen to Good Hang with you. Thank you, it's on Spotify.
你们俩在这一路走来的旅程中做得非常出色，你们的孩子简直不可思议，是伟大的人类。这是对你们最大的赞美。我只是爱他们，也爱你们。我想提醒大家去听你们的《Good Hang》。谢谢，在Spotify上。
And I have great guests coming out. Tina Fey is my first guest. No kidding. That's great. Yep, because you know, give America what they want. And then get Dax on there. Dax will give you some pointers. Yeah, Dax would be great.
而且我会有很棒的嘉宾。蒂娜·菲是我的第一位嘉宾。别开玩笑了。那太棒了。是的，因为你知道，给美国人他们想要的。然后让达克斯也上去。达克斯会给你一些建议。是的，达克斯会很棒的。
Can't wait. Yeah, any pointers guys, now that you're five years in? You can tell we've learned nothing. Yeah, zero. We're last people. I mean, if you guys can do it. It's true, anybody can do it. By the way, Amy, you won't be surprised that we haven't
等不及了。是的，有什么建议吗，伙计们，既然你们已经做了五年了？看得出来我们什么都没学到。是的，零。我们是最后的人。我的意思是，如果你们能做到。这是真的，任何人都能做到。顺便说一句，艾米，你不会惊讶我们已经
looked at comments forever, they'd always be like, their questions suck and they interrupt people all the time and I'm like, yeah, of course we do. What are you talking about? If you guys have taught me anything and taught all individually and collectively taught me so much, it's Don't overthink it. Don't overthink it. It's good. Unbelievable. We love you so much. We finally got you.
很久没看评论了，他们总是说，他们的问题烂透了，他们总是打断别人，我就说，是啊，当然了。你在说什么呢？如果你们教会了我什么，并且每个人都单独或集体教会了我这么多，那就是：别想太多。别想太多。这很好。不可思议。我们太爱你了。我们终于请到你了。
We love you, Amy. Thanks, guys. Thanks for having me on. It was so fun. Thank you, Amy. Okay, glad it was a fun surprise. Thanks, guys. It was such a good surprise.
我们爱你，艾米。谢谢你们。谢谢邀请我来。太有趣了。谢谢你，艾米。好的，很高兴这是一个有趣的惊喜。谢谢你们。这真是一个很好的惊喜。
I'm bringing the boys over. Okay. Can't wait. Bye. Bye, Amy. Thank you. Yeah, you got it. My pleasure.
我带孩子们过来。好的。等不及了。再见。再见，艾米。谢谢。是的，没问题。我的荣幸。
Bye. Bye. Bye, can't wait. Bye. Bye, bye, bye, bye. Bye, Aym, thank you. Yeah, you got it, my pleasure. So, well, that was fantastic to meet her. I've been such a fan of hers for, I don't know. Yeah. How funny.
再见。再见。再见，等不及了。再见。再见，再见，再见，再见。再见，艾米，谢谢。是的，没问题，我的荣幸。所以，嗯，见到她真是太棒了。我是她的粉丝已经，我不知道多久了。是的。多有趣啊。
I had no, you know what, when you were doing the intro, and of course I was like, and then she was like, oh, you didn't, I was like, it never occurred to me. You just thought it was coincidental that all, oh, well, you know, Amy did all those things. How did you guess it, Jay? From what? Because you said a queen of Massachusetts
我完全没……你知道吗，当你做介绍的时候，我当然是那种反应，然后她说，哦，你没……我当时想，我从来没想过。你只是觉得这很巧合，哦，好吧，你知道，艾米做了所有那些事情。你是怎么猜到的，杰伊？从什么猜到的？因为你说了一个马萨诸塞州的女王
or something like that. Oh, wow, you knew it just like that. Yeah, but I still, I had such a like, yeah. I love that you didn't know. I told Amanda last week. Oh, yeah. And yeah, she's like, oh. Amanda could work for the government.
或者类似的话。哦，哇，你一下子就知道了。是的，但我还是，我有一种……是的。我喜欢你不知道这一点。我上周告诉阿曼达了。哦，是的。然后她就说，哦。阿曼达可以为政府工作。
She is very good about keeping a secret. But the kids, Abel's here right now. He never said a word. I love that. God bless him. I love your face. I'm gonna go drag him out of his bed. How dare you?
她非常擅长保守秘密。但孩子们，阿贝尔现在就在这儿。他一个字也没说。我喜欢这一点。上帝保佑他。我喜欢你的脸。我要去把他从床上拖出来。你怎么敢？
That was right. Listen, it's not to get weird, but I hope you're as proud as you should be, and she as well. I mean, like, that went beautifully. Like, the fact that you guys not only have raised these two kids so well, but your relationship is so great and healthy and like, you could do a fucking one hour
那是对的。听着，不是要搞得怪怪的，但我希望你像你应该有的那样自豪，她也一样。我的意思是，那进行得太美好了。你们不仅把这两个孩子养育得这么好，而且你们的关系也这么棒、这么健康，就像你们可以在数百万人的面前做一个一小时的
podcast in front of millions of people and not have to fake anything. Like, it's just, you know, it's pretty admirable. I know it took, like full disclosure, like any couple that goes through the journey you've gone through, it took a while, but you're there now. Yeah, but you know, I am really proud of it. And of course it takes, things take a minute
播客，而且不需要伪装任何东西。这真是令人钦佩。我知道这花了一些时间，完全披露一下，任何经历过你们这种旅程的夫妻，都需要一段时间，但你们现在做到了。是的，但你知道，我真的为此感到自豪。当然，事情需要一点时间
because everybody's sort of adjusting to what it is, but I'm also very proud of, certainly as parents, what we've been able to do. And that, you know that has been really important to both of us. And yeah, I'm really, really lucky to have her as a partner in this way for us to parent this way. How lucky Archie and Abel are too, that you guys like worked out a brand new relationship
因为每个人都在适应现状，但我也非常自豪，作为父母，我们所能做到的。而且你知道，这对我们俩来说一直都很重要。是的，我真的很幸运能有她作为这种方式的伴侣，让我们以这种方式共同抚养孩子。阿奇和阿贝尔也很幸运，你们俩建立了一种全新的关系，
that serves you both and them. And it's- And I would say that I probably, you know, there aren't many people I speak to more than I speak to her, which is weird because, you know what I mean? Yeah, yeah. But it's great. I feel really lucky and I do still-
既服务于你们自己，也服务于他们。而且……我会说，我可能，你知道，没有多少人比我跟她说话更多，这很奇怪，因为，你知道我的意思吗？是的，是的。但这很棒。我感到非常幸运，而且我仍然……
Does Josh Shotlin get jealous at all or? He does, but she is somebody that I still run a lot of stuff by if I'm thinking of her. Does who get jealous? If Josh is not available. He's my buddy Josh that I FaceTime with. Oh, Josh, I didn't hear what you said, yeah. But I still, she's the person I go like,
乔什·肖特林会嫉妒吗？他会，但她是我仍然会征求意见的人，如果我想到她的话。谁会嫉妒？如果乔什没空的话。他是我经常视频通话的哥们乔什。哦，乔什，我没听清你说什么，是的。但我还是，她是那个我会去说，
hey, I'm thinking about doing this, or hey, whether it's life or work, and I really, I seek her counsel because it's important to me, because I trust her in that. Yeah, and she's a sharp cookie. She's awesome, she's awesome. What was the buy from the opening?
嘿，我在考虑做这个，或者嘿，无论是生活还是工作，我真的寻求她的建议，因为这对我来说很重要，因为我信任她。是的，她是个聪明人。她太棒了，她太棒了。开场时的那个“买”是什么意思？
It was a bicentennial, 250 episodes. That's right. So anyway, so guys, that was unbelievable and enjoy the rest of your day. No, it's our 250th episode, I can't believe it. That was unbelievable and enjoy the rest of your day. No, it's our 250th episode. I can't believe it. Wait, what?
那是两百周年纪念，250集。没错。所以，总之，伙计们，那真是不可思议，享受你们余下的一天吧。不，这是我们的第250集，我不敢相信。那真是不可思议，享受你们余下的一天吧。不，这是我们的第250集。我不敢相信。等等，什么？
Yeah. You remember 1976. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That was the 200th. That was the... Bye! San Antonio! Everybody! everybody. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael
是的。你记得1976年。是的，是的，是的。那是第200集。那是……再见！圣安东尼奥！每个人！每个人。《SmartLess》是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗伯·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴比科100%有机且手工制作的。SmartLess，罗伯·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴比科。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. SmartLess Rob Armjarf and Bennett Barbico. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
格兰特·特里、罗伯·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴比科。SmartLess 罗伯·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴比科。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。